[Music]
okay what's up everybody
and welcome to another wonderful edition
of the thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast i'm just
checking in on you with a very special
guest that i promised that i teased on
monday
ladies and gentlemen please welcome the
incredibly talented mr kevin bacon you
uh are you on the road i i heard you
were going to texas i think that's what
what yes i am this is the this is the
final night
eight nights 16 shows i realized how old
i am now
uh just doing 16 shows indoors would
have been hard enough but like
outside uh i feel like i've been yelling
at a tailgate for a week
how's it been going i mean first off uh
you know listen
uh a tailgate comedy doesn't doesn't
texas just say tailgate comedy that's
that's the place to do it right yeah but
you don't want to be
you don't want to be the only guy
talking at the tailgate i don't mind
chiming in and then having a couple of
beers used when i used to drink but it's
just sort of uh
the the first one we did was in dallas
which was a great venue but um
it was more of a music venue and there
was a highway nearby and it was like
final approach for like love field
there was a lot of stuff going on um but
the people have been like
just ridiculed like the fact that
they're gonna sit there in the cold
under blankets
listening to me do my uh dumb jokes
you know you know kind of it's like i
couldn't get too upset
with like i got frustrated because i
want to give them a show
uh so i got frustrated with a little bit
of the distractions on some of them but
like the fact that they were sitting
there the way they were
on cold grass under blankets i'm like
all right well i can't [ __ ] about this
too much so dallas was cool
uh i went to austin austin was crazy
uh those people got after it i thought
that they were going to be like super
mellow
you know the liberal town and it was
sort of
people yeah they were partying and then
i did one night last night here in uh
houston and they they were great they
were great so
well good for you man i mean i i first
of all i think your jokes are anything
but dumb
and uh i i think it's uh
i think that's really cool that you were
able to uh get out there and do your
thing
oh well yeah i mean i got a mortgage so
i got to get
it isn't just for uh for love of comedy
have you gone out and not done anything
i know you do the
bacon brothers stuff yeah no we d we
have not we've not
played um the bacon brothers actually
when the when the pandemic hit we were
actually in the studio
it's so weird to think back on the day
that we went into lockdown whatever was
march something
um we were finishing up the last record
we were doing a
bunch of songs in the in the studio and
and uh
it was at that moment before you know it
was kind of like pre-mask
but you were kind of not quite shaking
hands and
and uh doing a lot of like hand
sanitizer but we hadn't gone to the mass
thing yeah there was there was a glove
period people going to the grocery store
with gloves on i did that
right you didn't have a mask on or
nothing we were at that we were at that
glove period because we had to take the
gloves gloves off to play but
um uh you know it was um
we i haven't really done anything the
only thing i've done is i have gone back
to uh work on this series that i'm i'm
doing on showtime and
and that's been really interesting
because
you know it's really really weird to
start with because you get to work
your temperatures checked you go through
you'll answer a bunch of questions
everybody is in ppe you you're
completely you know massed up and and
shielded
those tests every time too yeah we get
tested probably
i mean four or five times a week uh they
for some reason the testing has
shifted a little bit where they're not
jamming it all the way up to your your
you know
uh brain it's just kind of like a spin a
spin around the lower nostril
and my wife said to me the other day she
said the testers must love you because
given the size of your nostrils you're
like a super easy target
i said thank you so much honey that's um
really sweet of you to point out
um and and we uh then at some
point after we've rehearsed
we have to take our masks off because
it's 1992
and we don't have masks on and um
at that moment that's when it feels
just like it used to feel
because now i'm acting i'm doing the
thing that i know how to do
i'm talking to actors the masks are gone
and you know the cameraman is shooting
it and the boom operators there and
everything is kind of like at least for
that moment feels
like right and the way it's supposed to
be but
hey is it weird to do like to go to be
doing a show now
going back in time during a time where
you were already
working in tv and film
do you do anything like it wasn't quite
like that
do they do they go to you to ask them
you know hey when you did these
i guess you know it's not it's not about
shooting a show but
one of my pet peeves is when i watch
something
in a period is greetings
like if i see one more high five in
something before the high five existed
or more than this you know that greeting
that came somewhere in the 90s
i'm with you yeah it drives me up the
wall it's just like
and plus i love the low five i miss that
yeah right
yeah i was watching something on that i
was like the high five didn't exist then
no that's that's really that's true i i
do the same thing i
you know i i'm i'm i'm old enough that i
don't really remember and sometimes i'll
go i'll see you
i'll see a high five or or you know
like a you know like a hug or something
and i'll go i
don't think that was but maybe i don't
know
i don't know i really remember you know
the other thing that's kind of about
that and you know when i was listening
to the other day you were talking about
drumming and you know learning the
zeppelin tune and stuff which i thought
was really fun to
listen to um and there's a really great
movie now
called the sound of metal i don't know
if you have a chance to see it yet but
it's a it i really would recommend it
and it's about a um
it's about a drummer in a in a in a
metal band
and he loses his hearing and
it's um it's a incredibly well done
and moving kind of moving the sound
design is is just
i really recommend it i have no
connection to it um
and my son looked at him my son plays in
in he's a guitar player
in a metal band and when you look at
something a movie that is like
specifically from your world like if i
would look at a movie
like you were mentioning before of
somebody making a movie i'd give it no
that's not right
oh like you know why isn't you know it
doesn't happen that way i sort of feel
the same way about music and i'm sure
you feel the same way when you look at
things that
involve drumming and and drummers and i
was talking to my son about the movie he
was like
yeah you know um i i really like
i really liked it but why did he have
that specific
t-shirt you know and it was like it was
like something that only
a metal head of would would would
would notice you know it's like it was a
band that he didn't think
that this guy would necessarily like
that band on his t-shirt right but
that's what happens when we watch movies
about things that we
know intimately but that's what makes
also something great
is if somebody can pay attention to that
level of detail like
a long time ago one of the first like
major acting things i got
is i got to do a couple episodes of
breaking bad
and they prided themselves on like
uh you know the trolls that would be
like oh it wouldn't happen that way
like they literally when we had a scene
it was a pallet of money
and that we laid down on um one of those
seasons
and they actually broke down the
denominations of
cash that mr white would have and how
big it would be
we did a train robbery thing and they
did the the math on the chemicals
they were taking out whatever the
chemical was to make the meth and then
putting water in
how much the density of it and there was
some guy whose job was to sit there and
shut down these trolls and be like no
it's exactly how
how much it would have been just for the
fun of it that's great so
yeah i i find that fascinating about
movies and movies can also create
something that never happened or tv
or or they'll they'll get like say like
with goodwill hunting
like the amount of people away from i go
i grew up just south of boston
and they'll be like oh yeah how do you
like them apples and i'm just like
nobody ever said that
when i was growing up that's the matt
damon joke
from goodwill hunting um or that movie
uh donnie brosco which ruined the
expression forget about it
it was so universal
and they just so overly described it
like to this day if i if i'd slips
because people tease me out of saying
i'd be like oh you went to that
steakhouse oh man forget about it was
unbelievable and then they go
forget about it and everybody's you feel
like an [ __ ]
yeah it ruins it forever i know i know
listen
i know i know exactly how you feel and i
i have to say that
you know just be speaking of of boston i
you know for some reason for
whatever reason i
have done a lot of movies in boston
yeah black mask uh mystic
mystic river patriots day mystic river
uh r-i-p-d
and now this show that i'm doing on
showtime my wife and i met in boston
during
doing a thing for wbga gbh
and um the one thing i know for sure
is that i've i've come to
i i have a sense of peace about the fact
that nobody from boston
is ever going to like my boston accent
and
that and i'm completely fine with that i
like i get it
i get it and what's really weird about
it is that i'm from philly
and philly has a
has a really specific accent but nobody
does it it's hard
well it's not that it's hard but
blossom's hard to i mean that it's not
it's that no but for some reason nobody
in the movie everybody goes to fill in
they talk like this they're like hey
what are you doing everyone from philly
it is from brooklyn somehow
miraculously and i don't really
understand why
why that is but but i've gotten a chance
to do
you know my own hometown accent like
like maybe maybe twice out of every
single movie i've
uh i've done and people don't even
really know that that's what i'm
i'm doing it's like a very it's a very
specific thing that
just for some reason we don't get
respect
i remember i met this this woman one
time she was from philly
she was a beautiful woman and was just
hearing that philly accent
like added to her beauty and i remember
she was talking about that added to her
beauty oh i'm glad to hear that i added
to it
because you know thought you were going
to say the opposite i thought i know it
was a buzzkill because she was trashing
somebody and she just he said something
like
yeah he's in the [ __ ] he kind of had
that weird way
i'm probably doing it wrong he's an
[ __ ] and just was like what the hell
was that
and then it was just just added like
another layer to it i think nick kroll
though
he actually got props i think he does a
good philly and pittsburgh
um um accent but like what does he do it
in because i want to check it out
or does he do his part he used to do
just going like youtube i'm sure the
clip is on there it's uh
k-r-o-l-l it was a sketch show brilliant
sketch show that he did on like uh
like three seasons on comedy central and
they did it they would do a sketch
where it was him and one other character
was a pittsburgh guy yelling at a philly
guy or something oh okay
i'll check it everybody i love nick yeah
yeah he did like
a uh i mean be honest with you it makes
you feel better people give me crap
about my boston accent if i lay into it
a little bit more
um but uh anyway
before we get too far into this i do
want to get into what uh you're
promoting here
this sounds like an amazing show so
here's the promo thing i'm going to read
here
forgive my reading out loud here but if
you listen to the podcast you're ready
for this here
uh celebrating uh the power of music to
make a change a prime time broadcast
concert special benefiting the naacp
legal defense and educational fund
incorporated and why hunger
hosted by our podcast guest here today
kevin bacon and eve
it's going to air on cbs on a new date
and time december 15th
8 o'clock eastern 7 central and exciting
additions to the musical lineup include
ll cool j
dj ztrip sara bareilles hope i said that
right emily king
pedrito martinez special guest bruce
springsteen john legend and ringo starr
i think you got enough of a show there
well we also have uh machine gun kelly
and ziggy marley and andre day and
uh bon jovi and marin morris and yola
and the high women and gary clark jr
and uh the list goes on and on it's it's
a it's a really
it's a really amazing um group of
musicians
um i like to say that if you like
music uh we'll have something for you
because we've
got rock and folk
and soul and rap
and uh reggae and country
and uh i actually think well but there's
no jazz but um
the great uh john batiste is doing a
cover of people get ready
uh from the apollo at the end of the at
the end of the show and he does a solo
that i would definitely
uh classify as jazz and he's got kind of
new orleans
uh chops um we
we are uh decided to
to do it from three different iconic
venues so it's
part of it was shot at the apollo in new
york and part of it was shot
at the troubadour in la and at the
bluebird
cafe in nashville which is a uh
fantastic sort of
singer-songwriter venue
and uh really proud of the show both for
the the messaging and for the the money
that we've raised for these fantastic
organizations but also for the musical
side of it because i know that um you
know you you play
and i'm sure that you've seen during um
the pandemic that people have done some
sort of collections of
music from home and it's a it's it's fun
it was kind of charming at the beginning
to see somebody just you know with
acoustic guitar kind of you know singing
their songs
from the living room or there's been uh
on the other extreme
these very big production numbers with
no audience which
uh you know can sometimes feel i don't
know a little
a little strange i think that we've
really hit the sweet spot here for
uh these these musicians are together
and they're playing live
and they're having a great time and
they're in these really super cool
venues but we're not trying to pretend
that there's
people that are listening to them that
sounds amazing that almost
makes reminds me of um what was that
documentary it might get loud
and they just said jack white and the
edge and jimmy page they were just
sitting in a circle
or like uh you ever watch on youtube you
ever watched that live from daryl's
house
daryl hall i've been on it oh you've
been on that yeah i was watching one
from this morning one of my um
uh i always forget his name from uh
james gang and the eagles
was on it um the guitar player there
oh joe walsh yo walsh yeah oh my god
they do this version of
uh that whatever life's been good to me
so far
and just it is just a sonic masterpiece
and um just being like i always call
myself uh uh
you know a dad drummer is basically what
i am
and there's just something about
professional musicians
just listening to them tuning up is so
much better than anything i've ever done
and just how they all like lock in and
uh the fact that you guys are gonna all
be at the
venues i'm psyched that you're on here
to promote this because
this is something with you know just
being on the road i might have missed it
and uh i've been able luckily enough to
perform at two of those
two out of the three of those venues um
survived the apollo
and uh i'm sure you did i'm sure you did
well i remember doing doing the gig
and this dude just sitting sideways like
this the whole time getting ready to get
up
my whole set never left but he never
turned around
but doesn't that is isn't that a great
challenge
that you just keep your eye on them and
you go what are you still in your seat
you're still in your seat [ __ ] i
haven't i got another one you haven't
left yet
well i remember standing in the alley
behind there
waiting to go on and it was taped it was
it was the summer time it was august to
2000 so you know
even though it was like the late
afternoon the sun was still
out and i remember hearing somebody
getting booed
and don't and going like you know i
really didn't need to do this
i'm a perfectly good white guy i could
have just stayed in the white guy clubs
why am i doing this and what was funny
is i had met my future wife like two
seconds before that but i was so busy
focusing i met nia who and uh her dad
was booking it
and he was leading up the stairs i
remember he had a look at concern on his
face
he's probably reacting to the look on my
face um
so and then of course the troubadour you
know i'm a huge music fan and all that
and uh
it's how how have you been able to uh
with as busy
as you are like throughout the years
i've always
been a mate like i've really envied your
career as far as all the great work that
you've done
you seem to you stay out of trouble you
know which is a hard thing to do now as
a comic it seems you stay out of trouble
and you're also able to do
this music thing with with your brother
and get involved in these charities
you know keep the home life together
like uh
you seem on paper you're one of the most
sane people in this business
like how are you able to do that um
i you know i i don't know i mean i feel
like
um i really really love
uh what i do um
and i've worked really hard to be able
to keep doing it
through the years you know uh because
it's it's something that i i i just get
i still get a tremendous amount of
pleasure out of
you know um the time between action and
cut
is like such a sweet spot for me and and
every time i don't care what you know
what kind of piece of [ __ ] i'm doing
i i still really enjoy you know uh
pretending to be another person um in
terms of my own
personal life i think i uh met the right
person
people say you know why how do you stay
married for so long and
and it's a really hard question to ask
uh
on the last record we had a song called
play
and and that i wrote about as sort of as
a
kind of a wise-ass response to that
because everyone says oh boy it's
so much work isn't it you got to really
work at it you know be to have a
successful marriage it's got to be a
while out of work and i i said
no really to me it's really about
playing you know
you got to have the play that's got to
be the part part of it you know
yeah you're still able and and that's
that's what's what
what i feel with with uh with
kira and um
i don't know man you know uh i try to
wake up every day with
a lot of um gratitude for
uh having a roof having food having um
love in my life a lot of things that a
lot of people certainly
during this time difficult time don't
have
and also for being able to make a living
doing what i really really love to do
yeah that's
that's uh that's incredible i've already
been out here
you know i started late in the game as
far as getting married and having kids
and all that type of stuff
and um it's made the road is a different
it's a really different thing when you
have
something that you're leaving that you
actually want to be still a part of
so thank god for like zoom and all of
that type of stuff and like i don't zoom
i mean like facetime in that thing
because uh i've been able to be out here
for as long as i have
right now like eight days which is
something i usually wouldn't do
i just kind of needed to like i said i
got bills to pay here so
um but just being able to face time with
my kids
and to also see because i remember early
on in my career when i should have been
i guess getting married if i wasn't such
a lunatic
and having kids i remember my friends
telling me like man i went on the road
for the week and i came back and like my
daughter's face changed
and and all of a sudden you know she's
starting to walk and i miss that
so the fact that i get videos and things
like that
have been uh it's huge it's huge when
when when facetime first came out
we used to say oh god bless steve jobs
that was like all
all that was like our mantra god bless
steve jobs because
we we're you know we're a couple that
um and a family really that
even though we on the surface look like
you know well they have
you know we're sort of home home bodies
we're really vagabonds
at our core we are our marriage has been
really based on two suitcases being
packed and ready to
go and and that's been a plus and the
and the minus i mean because clearly you
know you're gonna
be forced to spend some time apart but
it actually has been part of what's kept
us together
is the fact that you know we like to be
with each other we like to be home but
we're always kind of ready to go
okay i'm going off to work you're going
off to work and for a long time it made
things really complicated when it came
to bringing the kids back
and forth and stuff like that but to be
able to reconnect
with somebody you know
once a day or whatever is really great
and if you could do it on face time
um even even better and um
this time has been really strange
because
you know when when the pandemic you know
rolled into town
i immediately flew to la where she was
and we went
into lockdown together and went through
i don't know probably four months or
five months or whatever
it was just like the two of us in the
same house and
that's something that's never happened
in our marriage ever after
32 years we've been married we've never
spent that much time together
ever and you know
we don't have a big house out there but
luckily we have
like she could go into the bedroom and i
could go into the living room or
something so like in the course of the
day
we would sort of like kind of separate
then we'd get together we'd have lunch
and then we'd separate for a while then
we'd get back together and we had dinner
um a lot of people didn't have that kind
of luxury
but we it was a it was an adjustment
to actually be spending that much time
together and one that we
survived luckily and now
i'm on a show in new york she's on a
show in l.a so she went out to l.a now
we've been separated for the longest
period that we've ever been separated in
our marriage
so these are two sort of like milestones
i've never been apart from her
for um for this long and
uh you know we're getting through that
as as best we can so
it's um you know it's it's interesting
that you're
you're uh you know just kind of coming
to that now
and um oh dude i have i have a zillion
dad
questions for you how did your son find
music because i love playing but i don't
want to force it on him
but you know it's like you want to be
like come on man you play guitar i play
drums i can jam with my own kid would be
the greatest thing ever
um and she goes kind of through periods
of liking drums
and playing guitar and but she's really
she has a toy guitar she's really
getting into it so i'm trying not to be
that
how old is she uh she'll be four in
january
well i don't know if this is too hippy
dippy but i used to play a lot too
to her belly when when she was pregnant
um he came out and
one of his first words or if not his
first word was guitar
and he wanted me to make him uh
little cut out guitars all the time like
and i would draw pictures of them and
then
then you want me to cut them out and
then they would pick the the uh
the paper would bend and he'd get upset
so then i would have to take cardboard
and make it stiffer and glue it against
the thing and then eventually he'd break
that and he'd cry and then i'd have to
make him another guitar and i was
like constantly making guitars until i
could finally get a toy a toy one
and he was really really like um
obsessed with he was not into
none of the sports not into uh any
anything you know with a ball so much
and then he found uh
swords and like most boys and then he
found guns
and then he found video games and they
got
you know more and more you know
increasingly more violent and you know
this is a kind of real right right
it was unbelievable yeah well they
weren't the
so we're talking about he he's he's 32
now so we're talking about
but it was a it was an earlier kind of
iterate they weren't as real as they are
now
when he was about probably i'd say
10 he stopped playing
the video game and he picked up the
guitar
and i took that video game and put it up
in the closet he's he's never played
again
he's he's that's he just has been doing
music ever
ever since then so i can't say that i
forced it on him i mean yeah i got him
lessons like adam gear if he wanted i
look i mean if somebody if somebody
wants an instrument
i say get him the instrument people
don't get hurt making music
you know people um
making music is a is a is a strong and
peaceful and powerful thing to to
do uh you can you can bang the [ __ ] out
of your
your drums and you know the only thing
you you risk
risk of hurting is your ears and you
know i guess when you get to be real old
you can get some
you know tendinitis or whatever yeah
yeah this one yeah yeah but but you know
it's it's a it's a beautiful thing to
make music
and um we always had uh you know
we always had gear around always guitars
around always always um
drums around i mean there's always
percussion around here right now and
and uh um it's was just
uh there was access to it and and
there's something really cool on your
website for your charity6degrees.org
where you kind of use where you are in
the world to
shine a light on these charities that
people just needed some attention to
they're all great causes and the one
that that really appealed to me there
was something about helping
schools get instruments for their
students
and uh i went to public school and we
got instruments
like in philadelphia the philadelphia
public school system back in the in the
uh 50s and 60s
if you wanted to play something they
just gave you they gave you the
you know the trumpet or the flute or the
violin or you know whatever it was
along with lessons and stuff not just i
don't think that really exists anymore
and i think that why do you think that
is because i live out in los angeles and
it's like
like the public school systems it's like
not even an option you got all of these
people there
you know paying taxes and all of this
type of stuff
like ridiculous level taxes and
you know when you go to the public
schools i don't is it because do you
think
i was trying to come up with a theory
like i just think like raising a kid's a
lot more expensive where
you know getting your kid ready for
school for the school year you bought
them a new pair of
sneakers couple pairs of pants some
shirts and then
some crayons pen and pencil and they
were good to go you didn't have to get
them like
a cell phone and laptops right
and like i mean a laptop is like i mean
essentially
it's like you're buying your kid like a
new used car
yeah every year or two yeah that's a
good point
rich kid yeah i i never thought of that
uh i think it was also that there was
more
i don't know more funding for for the
uh you know that in in in the in the
public school system it just seems like
you know if you're going to cut
something
people feel that uh music and
instruments and
you know music in general is something
that is is on the chopping block pretty
pretty quickly uh yeah they feel like
it's a silly thing like it's a
uh i think they almost put it up there
they put it somewhere like in
like gym class as far as level of uh
importance which is i don't know that's
strange to me but um people listening if
you want like
kevin has this amazing um charity
right i'm saying that right yep um
what i like about it is you're not just
funneled
into this one thing you had like this
wide variety of like whatever you're
into
you know pediatric cancer all the way to
uh
getting instruments for kids so there's
kind of like
something there for everybody but um
i don't know um another connection
another dad question i got a few of
these because
you know yeah yeah man yeah i i so
did you go through like i don't know if
this happened to you but like i find i
try to avoid talking
about being a parent with most parents
because they seem to want to focus gloom
and doom on
like whatever you'd like whatever your
kid is they feel like if their kid's a
little bit older
like nothing good is gonna happen and
it's always like oh you wait and it's
kind of like well each kid is different
just because you're dealing with that
doesn't mean that i'm gonna deal with it
and how do i know you're even
involved and they'll be like how old
your kid turning four oh you wait you
wait
the next year is gonna be yeah blah blah
blah
and you wait till they become teenagers
did um
i would think that there's at some point
they're going to act out and that's like
my biggest
i just don't want to go through or try
to minimize i know at some point they
got to like test boundaries and
you know break free of you and
everything i just don't want to go
through this period
where my kid doesn't feel that they can
come to me
and be like all right look last night i
was at a party and x y and z
was going down maybe i did this so i was
thinking about doing that and feeling
that they can come to me
and it's not going to be this um
that's it you're never seeing your
friends again and all of that type of
stuff did
how are you able to navigate those years
where
all of a sudden it's like okay i'm going
out with my friends
and you and you're really what you know
it's not even you're worried about your
kid you're at the mercy of
how did these people raise those kids
yeah
are now driving my kid down the street
that's that's a good that's a good point
i remember i guess i hadn't really
thought all
about that that much but yeah that's
true you do think about that
uh the other people um
well listen i totally agree with you
that that it can be a
real uh it could be a real street bad
streak to walk down to even
raise this topic with people and people
do want to tell you a lot of gloom and
doom and that's when
when they you know subjects like oh it's
the terrible
twos that's gonna be it's like oh great
so the entire year
that this kid is two years old this is
gonna be a [ __ ] nightmare for me you
know and that's not true i mean it
starts
it starts uh with the with the with the
birth i mean
if if uh if if you start talking to
people about what what
child birth is gonna be like don't just
don't even do it because it's gonna
you're just gonna be like no [ __ ] it i'm
out this is
this is gonna be a disaster um i
remember when my kid was cool and wasn't
terrible
when she was two yeah you know what then
they said they said oh that means your
next one's going to be a lunatic
this one's cool the next one's going to
be a lunatic so my son is six months old
and he's he's he's the best right
like smiles with his whole face and he's
just in a good mood
and like loves his older sister and
she loves him and everything so you just
can't fall into
that you just can't fall into that trap
and this is what i this is what i tell
people
whatever it is you might even sort of
know this already
um you when you're in some
situation like let's say it's uh
the diaper thing or the toilet training
thing or whatever
you're like oh my god this like
this is a [ __ ] nightmare i i don't
know how
and it feels like it's going to last
forever a lot of these phases
feel like they're going to last forever
whatever it happens to be
right uh right up through um you know
whatever
partying and or bad grades or you know
stuff that you're talking about down the
line with the you know
with the teenagers it passes
it's a cliche but this too shall pass
these
phases um if you can have some kind of a
trust
that there's something on the other side
of it that's number one that's the thing
that i
i try to uh you know
try to share with with people rather
than try to give them a warning that the
shit's gonna get bad
um but the other thing is that
the best your kids are gonna have to
have secrets from you
eventually they are if they don't have
seek if they don't have some secrets
from you then
they're not growing up i mean i didn't
tell my parents everything
i can't i don't want i don't want my
parents to be my best friend
and i don't want to be my children's
best friend if they have a friend that
they can tell their secrets to
then that's great but we've tried
as best we can this is really this this
um
uh by the me i feel like we're getting a
little too deep but but this has been
driven home by
by my wife really she's she's been the
leading the charge on this particular
thing
and that is to to try as best as
possible to keep the lines of
communication
open and to uh
be uh open-hearted and
and honest and
put them in a situation where if they
share something
with you it doesn't mean that they're
going to get punished
for it because then
you then you can just kind of work your
way through these things that are going
to come up there's going to be hurt
there's going to be sadness you know
somebody's going to get
you know drunk cry some point i guess
you know
i mean that's i mean and
um you know i think we also
have been pretty open with sharing our
own personal experiences about the
the struggles that we've had growing up
and the things that we went up to a
point you know up to a point i don't
think we've shared everything with them
we gotta have your secrets too yeah we
gotta have our secrets too yeah
yeah but it's it's gonna be okay
all right so you grew up during an
amazing time i feel
like i feel like you you were born 10
years before me
and just the bands that you got to see
growing up um and considering that you
are a musician
were you a big uh i know concerts are
expensive for kids but did you get to go
see
a lot of those amazing bands when you
were coming up okay so i had this crazy
thing happen
where i as you know i grew up in
philadelphia and
uh a kid moved in around the corner from
me when i was six years old
named harry spillback and uh
we became friends i like you know met
him on the street and
you know he was new to the neighborhood
and and we became friends
turns out his dad uh
they owned um restaurants and clubs
in in philly and uh
they owned a venue
called the electric factory which was
um a in those days they called it a
disco tech but it was a
no alcohol uh music venue we're talking
about
probably 19 i don't know
i was born at 58 so probably 1966 or
something like that 67
we started to go to shows there and as
little kids
so i saw janice with big brother in the
holding company
what i saw delaney and bonnie
i mean we would go up to the the uh the
light tower
and um they were they were you know
putting a colored dye onto a onto a
little slide and doing the psychedelic
kind of projection onto the stage so as
a little kid i actually
um you know experienced that whole
60s thing even though i was born 58 i
was really
young to be seeing it and then
that that club uh eventually shut down
uh the mayor of philadelphia tried to
shut it down because he
thought it was a den of iniquity and you
know drugs and all that
uh the guys named frank rizzo but they
were able to stay open and then they
closed and then they
started uh electric factory concerts
which was at the spectrum in philly
and then we started going to all the you
know that's when the stadium brock
happened and you know i
you don't want to know i mean i saw i do
want to know i saw zeppelin and i saw
the stones
i saw uh you know stones like multiple
times i mean i can't even remember
you know what what tour did you see
zeppelin on what year
uh i guess it would be gosh i don't know
you would know what the actual tour but
i'm guessing it's somewhere around
72 73 like early 70s some early 70s tour
or zeppelin iv or something like that oh
my god what what is did he have the the
vista light kit the orange i don't
remember
his kid milk i know i'm sorry i know i
know
what's funny i can barely remember the
concerts that i went to would anybody
but that's hilarious that's hilarious
what kind of kit was he playing on
when you were 11 did you take the time
did you go to a podcast
50 years later that's amazing well we do
a segment on this podcast believe it or
not people
write in and they asked me for uh advice
and stuff so i was wondering just to
switch it up here if you
if you uh i'll read these questions and
maybe
uh you know you can weigh in we can get
some advice
from incredibly successful man with a
big heart helping people out here
starting his
i'll do my best okay that's all we
that's all we do on here there's no
pressure you can always pass
all right uh musicals says dear billy
boo brain whatever the hell that means i
had a dream i had a dream last night
that you were announced to be
in a remake of the wizard of oz
uh because it was a dream i was not able
to read the article clearly but i was
incessantly
trying to figure out who you were cast
as
uh despite this project not being on
anyone's agenda
i really need to know who who you would
play
my initial reaction is the scarecrow for
obvious reasons scarecrow didn't have a
brain
is that it i always get confused about
that i think the scarecrow didn't have a
brain right
the tin man needed a heart and the line
needed courage
and dorothy had to get home all right
but i also like i also think you could
be a killer tin man
because your joints are all tight from
that 80s lifting regimen
this is really not really not advice
you're just kind of [ __ ] on me
you could probably nail uh as a
representative of the lollipop guild
with your cracked smile grin and little
kicking legs
this is the internet you know i'm sure
you're familiar with this there's never
any comp there's no compliments on the
internet
i need some answers on this so i can get
on with my life well you know what
you can trash me who do you i think i'd
be one of those little
little pusions whatever you call them
you know what
you know what i see you as bill and
don't take this the wrong way i see you
as one of the flying monkeys
you know what i like about that is
you're still the producer you're also
going like
what kind of box office is this guy
going to bring in if he's one of the
leads
let's give him a flying monkey thing
we'll see how he does
um how come i can't be the little wizard
behind the curtain
i think you can be a little wizard
behind the curtain i think i don't know
i i i need some advice because i know
that you
for a while you got typecast off your
early movies so then you had to play
against type
so i keep playing cops and uh
boston guys yeah what what is what is my
against tight move here
i keep playing cops in boston guys
you know i listen i um
in fact uh i'll tell you a funny story
just
an aside i i checked into uh
to start the pilot on on city on a hill
which is the one i'm doing now for
showtime
this is you know a year or two ago and
uh i'm staying right on the common and
uh
i get to the hotel and i i leave the
my car with the with the the you know
the
valet and i take my dog my dog was with
me so i was taking my dog into the
comment take a
take a leak and this guy's sitting in
the car and he goes hey
how come you get to play all the boston
cops
and i'm like totally out of the blue
and i was like what what and he just he
just repeated
that again and it was just such a funny
was such a funny
boston thing also that he was kind of
like wise ass
and sort of you know busting my
it was it was kind of aggressively kind
of like busting my balls but
in a in a sort of funny like
kind of cool way and i was like i really
don't know and clearly i think he was an
actor
i mean i think he was an actor and i
think he probably had put together that
here i was rolling into town once again
you know staying at the [ __ ] four
seasons and and uh
properly square and taking yeah and
taking and
and taking one of his roles yeah i get
people back there
like dude how come you're doing all this
[ __ ] i'm funnier than you are
this is funny you weren't that funny
when we were in math classes just get
off like
hey i mean there's open mics man you can
go do them but by the way i got to give
you props on the boston accent how can
you get to play all the boston cops you
got that
r sound down everybody thinks because of
the joke
the pactica and the hobbit yard that the
whole thing is that ah sound they don't
understand that
that's just what you know an ar sort of
at the end of a word
and they miss that boston because i'll
say where you're from i'll say boston
and they go oh boston
and i'm like did i say it like that it's
b a w like bar like
saw that that is my life's work is to
just get people to at least say that the
name of the city uh correctly so as
formula i mean i haven't lived there
since 95 but that sounded pretty damn
good to me
so i don't have a problem with you
playing all the boston cops you [ __ ]
sucker
all right okay so that's one line i've
i've i've
scored with one line good oh you got it
it was good it was good that's something
to build on
all right underrated music parts dear
billy crescendo
i love discovering parts to a song that
are usually overshadowed by more famous
parts
i.e the drum part in sultan's of swing
is very underrated oh that was nice this
is obscure
this is a very obscure music question i
like this yeah
okay good uh the legendary mach napla
uh guitar solo
certainly steals the show i'll just do a
boston accent for the rest of it you
have it down
uh but the drum part is such a solid
groove i was wondering if there were any
parts that made you feel the same way
another one for me is the piano parts
pink floyd's us
and them the addition is usually
on the awesome female vocal part where
she's wailing at the end
may the force be with you in order to go
[ __ ] yourself love the podcast and happy
holidays yeah there's a
i mean of course i'm gonna go blank but
for some reason i think because we were
talking boston
um there's a part there's a drum
uh aerosmith joey kramer on get your
wings
there's a song i forget the name of it
um
but it's it's like this last song the
first side she's a woman of the world
the god she knows it
well there's a breakdown in the middle
when the band kind of
drops out and it's just joey kramer just
laying down this simple
groove but it just sounds so [ __ ]
good
that i used to i used to like wear out
the record just
trying to figure out because you know
you know that stuff when you first start
playing be like
physically i can play this but i can't
make it sound that good
sure it's like this magical thing so i
would say something like that
what about you oh wow uh that's such a i
mean i find that to be a really
interesting
question she's not talking about just
drums because she mentions another
instrument it's a
at one point but it's kind of like the
you know what they think she said
yeah piano thing yeah it's kind of like
that that
thing of um well i guess it's kind of
like
where you go what really made this
um a hit and is there some kind of
unsung
hero and god there's always these unsung
heroes in
in music right i mean but you know one
thing that just popped into my head was
um
no no no no that that mike campbell
lick in um uh that tom petty song what
song is it
all i hear is the lick now um breakdown
breakdown i guess it's breakdown yeah
you know and and it's like nobody
i love my camel i mean i think his his
you know that you don't go
like people would never really talk
about him in the
top top top sort of like you know jimmy
pages
kind of echelon of of guitar players but
and maybe maybe tom wrote that like i
don't know but but
i always look at that like to me like
without
i love that song breakdown but but like
that lick is a really really important
part of it and it's a really simple
thing right it's like super super simple
so that's one that just popped into my
head thank you
thank you uh alyssa from i don't know
i that you know i'm a big fan of bands
that never sounded the same when the
drummer left
uh i think that's such a statement of
the drummer and i think i still love tom
petty throughout his whole career
and steve ferroni and everything but
when stan lynch was in the band it was a
different
sounding band guns and roses the same
thing too you know i love matt sorum
um but like when when um uh stephen
adler was in it it was just a different
he had just this such a unique
feel i never felt like a guy who he had
like this punk sort of background when
he was pushing the band while being laid
back and swinging at the same time it
was the weirdest
coolest feel uh feel i've ever heard
from a drummer at least during that
period all right
so now we got dumb questions uh for
employees so a lot of people work with
the general public and they get asked
stupid questions i don't know if you
ever had one of those oh you were a
waiter right
i was a waiter yeah i was a waiter and a
busboy yeah so i'm sure you got plenty
of dumb questions so
this is i guess the immigrant edition
so hey billy no mates i actually know
what that means because i knew this
english chick
and uh she told me that's an expression
if you're alone in a pub they say
hey look look at billy no mates
you know what it was because when i was
on the road i used to go to baseball
games by myself
so i had all these pictures of me in
front of these baseball stadiums where i
was by
myself and a stranger's holding the
camera
so she goes you should do a coffee table
book called billy no mates
in front of all of these stadiums it's
actually a decent idea
yeah um all right hey billy no mates i'm
an immigrant from england
manchester specifically now living in
the midwest i love the feature of people
writing in with their dumb questions
they get at their jobs my stuff is
pretty run in the middle but i remember
i've been
but remember i've been i remember being
asked some pretty [ __ ] stupid
questions since moving here
so here goes all right so this is some
english guy i guess who came here
uh so do you guys celebrate 4th of july
what do you do we go to work like any
other weekday
all right this might not be something
that you can participate in i realize
that i'm i'm new i'm new to this
interviewing thing
uh how well great okay thank you
how often do you get back to london
never i'm from manchester well how the
hell would they know that
this guy's a [ __ ] all right you guys
only drink
[Laughter]
you guys only drink which is an
interesting word to use because that's a
very different meaning in england than
it does in the in the states as you know
oh it is an art form over there it's you
i like that better than going to go see
big ben or something is hearing people
in great britain ireland uh saying
uh [ __ ] is one of my favorite things
the scottish were the best the
complimentary [ __ ]
is the greatest like eyes a great
[ __ ] i'm like i want to meet this guy
i got to meet this great guy you know
there's uh actually
what what what i found out was that well
first of all i hate i can't stand my
name
and i've i found out that that's it's
often
used as an insight insult in property
you know and which kind of means i don't
know
just sort of jerk or you know
yeah that's like the kick karen over
there or something like that yeah
yeah right exactly yeah yeah um i was i
was thrilled to hear that
all right well we're gonna wrap up here
i appreciate i can't believe you came on
before
before we wrap up i just want to tell
you one thing and that is that
i was listening to you um i guess it was
last monday or whatever
and you went off about your um your
car your dream car thing switching from
uh i think what was it originally a fair
lane or something
what was it i'm a truck guy and then for
a while i was obsessed with 67 cadillac
el dorados and for whatever reason
el dorado right yeah and and now you've
moved into the bronco well
you know kovid has
you know sometimes there's been weird
impulses that have happened and
during this uh virus i bought a 69
bronco
no you didn't yeah yeah wow
is it all original had it been redone
what what it's all
yeah it's all original i mean i put uh
not me
because i i know nothing about working
out cars but i did i did
put in um uh disc brakes
uh just for people
because people cut out in front of you
like like like you got
you don't have drum brakes and i that's
what i did on uh a buddy of mine helped
me do that on just on the front i still
got the shoes in the back but
but it's got no roof it's got no windows
it's got no doors
uh it's got a you know a front window
obviously did it shift on the column
or is it on the column then to tell you
the truth i know how to drive
i know how to drive a stick shift i mean
i have since i was a
young but i don't think i'd ever drive
driven three on a tree so i'm on [ __ ]
youtube
how do you drive three on the tree and
uh
and i i literally learned it on youtube
i bought my truck out of atlanta
um street side customs a little shout
out to them and they sent me this uh
68 ford f-100 oh that's where you have a
68 f-100
oh my god yeah oh i didn't know that no
i thought you were talking about an 82
bronco you wanted oh i
like that too like if i had like if i
had my dream garage it would look like
the opening
uh scene in no country for old men when
all those
all the dead dudes are in it because
those are all fords i love i'm not
really into 78 79 fords but i like
everything else
but do you still have the other one yeah
i do
oh wow so uh it was three on the tree
and how i figured it out
was i just slowly let out the clutch and
it didn't stall
so i'm like all right that's first
and then straight up i figured out i
learned was reversed because i'm
thinking i'm gonna go fast let me go
back
am i all right that's right and then i
just sort of work
i i was on you know i didn't don't live
on a busy street and i sort of figured
it out i was like all right so this is
just like an h so it's reverse
first second third and
um it it i've really kept it
i just updated a few things like the
those
trucks ran a little hot and so i got an
aluminum uh radiator we put that in
and then also the intake manifold
weighed like as much as a battleship
so when i had the engine rebuilt they
said you know they make an aftermarket
thing out here
of uh that's more made out of a lighter
metal i forget what it was but it's just
as fine you know you know just as good
that's also
it's not fuel injected though is it no
no no this thing ran
on regular gas and the problem was was i
was trying to learn how to do that
treatment
you know you have to dump the stuff in
and i didn't know to do that
so i burned out a little bit of it so
that's when it got
it had to get like rebuilt so i've only
done a few things i think we uh we
changed a little bit of the gearing in
the differential or whatever just to
give me a little bit of help
because with three gears i would take
that thing on
the highway if i had to go somewhere if
i was driving it that day i'd have to
stay in the slow lane but
it was just really starting i felt i
felt like i was redlining it at like 50
miles an hour so
it just gave me a little more if i can
go like 60 65 but
i really realized as much as i like
watching people go fast i
i like cruising around that's why i like
a caddy i like a pickup truck
and stuff like that although i've become
the same thing you know i don't i
i you know i'm up in uh northwestern
connecticut here
and i'm never going to take to take to
i'm never going to take the bronco on
the highway
uh i've never taken it off i've i'm
barely hitting 50.
and my daughter said to me so basically
you got this so that you could drive
like three miles down the road and you
know buy some apples
and then turn around and come home i was
like yeah it really is i think that's
all employable is it too it's that's
what i miss
about being in la that's not like a
country road that yeah i look at that
truck it's like that thing should be on
like a country road
and i did some gigs in connecticut and
we were staying at a house
more like southwest connecticut i was
trying to be between you know boston and
new york
and um i mean it's god's country out
there
after you live out here in the desert
it's on fire now
for like three months out of the year it
seems um
i was thinking like like this is the
place
to have a classic car this is a place
where you you know
you could have like a motorcycle he
could be on a back road and not feel
like every five seconds somebody texting
is gonna like end your life so that's
cool man i'm really
are you one and done with the old cars
or uh is just starting
no i am i used to have a uh i used to
have a uh
a 61 um uh austin healey bug-eye sprite
so it's kind of like the two extremes
yeah i don't know that
it's a um it's like a little they're
they're cute they're like
it's like kind of like a triumph for or
an mg like a tiny
tiny little british racing car it's got
these crazy um
bug eye headlights but uh i saw that
that was a car
that you really needed to know how to
work
on cars because basically i'd take it
out once and then it
wouldn't start and so it was constantly
in the shop and i was like i don't
i'm not the guy that knows how to do
that um but
uh but yeah i i'm not i'm not i'm not
going to be a
collector it's it's i i like this thing
um it's you know it's i'm
i've just i just took it out and uh
turned it over just because i need to
but i don't think i'm going to drive it
again this winter because
it's really cold i mean it's got no
doors
and uh with tonka trucks and i think
that that's where i just never
grew out of that and my dream as a kid
was i wanted to have a big four-wheel
dive truck with those
those the lights up on top of the roof
all right
when i was a kid and i saw somebody
driving down the street at dusk
and all they had on was just the what
not to have what do you call the fog
lights
right there i just thought that that was
the coolest thing
like i wanted a job where i would have
an excuse to drive that truck
by the way those early 80s broncos that
you're
like buying those are incredibly
expensive cars now
i mean they some of those have been
outfitted they're like over two hundred
thousand dollars
oh that's if they do like that yeah they
do okay
i don't i don't get having a 200 000 car
it's like where am i gonna go with this
i'll be afraid to take it anywhere and
then somebody like some piece of [ __ ]
i don't get it i don't get it either but
they are very
they are they're they're hot now because
you know uh
ford's coming out with a new bronco and
i think that kind of makes people
into the oil but i like the full-size
one so and the years that i like i like
80 to 86 and those things for whatever
didn't catch on but that's just when i
was a kid there was somebody in my uh
my high school had a uh had a green
ford f-250 four-wheel drive i don't know
what year it was but i remember they'd
gone off-road and came to school to look
cool and the whole thing was covered in
mud except the windshield where the
wipers were
and when i was a kid i was like that's
the coolest [ __ ] thing i've ever seen
i gotta get one of those one of those
days but of course i didn't i had the
little
little two wheel drive ford ranger
with the little am fm radio was sort of
uh
an omen for my uh my high school
experience so
anyways but i am real i'm so glad you
came on this podcast i'm such a huge fan
back at you man i i love i love your
[ __ ] i really do you're you're really
you're really funny and you're really
smart and i really enjoy it
oh thank you so much and so december
15th
um what is the name of the thing
primetime broadcast
leon what's it called play on clay on
okay it's going to be on cbs
8 o'clock eastern 7th central with the
great kevin bacon kevin thank you so
much
continued success and enjoy that bronco
okay thanks bill
all right buddy we'll see you thank you
bye-bye all right
all right now the advertising here we go
movement watches
everybody movement mvmt we all know that
2020 isn't playing
by any of the usual rules and that goes
for holiday shopping too
between shipping delays and the mess and
stress of shopping in stores
right now uh there aren't great options
but our friends over at movement watches
have made getting
made gifting easy mvmt makes clean and
modern watches eyewear
blue light glasses and jewelry getting
great quality and style
doesn't have to break the bank did you
freeze up andrew
no no okay you're just looking sorry
sorry
movement uh everscroll blue light
fillering filtering glasses are a
personal favorite with lenses that
protect your eyes from long hours in
front of your screens
oh those are great they come in tons of
fashion forward styles to choose from
gif give the gift of better sleep better
focus and better style i'm going to buy
myself some of those with the blue
lenses because it brings out my life
uh movement has been the super sleek
matte black packaging
oh has this super sleek matte back black
packaging
just add a bow and you're good to go
their products are one size fits all
and their gift guides help you find the
gift that fits their style
their shop their shipping is fast and
they offer free returns
all the way into next year not that
you'll need it get 15
off today with fast free shipping with
free and free returns
by simply going to mvmt.com
all right simply safe everyone you know
everyone wants to keep their home and
family safe
whether it's from a break-in a fire
flooding
or a medical emergency be great if they
could screen for annoying friends too
simply safe home security delivers
award-winning 24
7 protection with simply safe you don't
just get an
arsenal of cameras and sensors you get
the best professional monitors
in the business uh they've got you back
day and night ready to send police
fire or emts when you need them most
straight uh when you need them most
straight to your door sorry simply safe
has an arsenal of sensors and cameras
that protect every inch of your home you
can set it up yourself in about 30
minutes it's super easy
then simply safes professionals take
over monitoring your home 24
7 and ready to send help the moment
there's an alarm
uh plus was simply safe there's no
long-term contract no hidden fees
or installation costs right now my
listeners get a free home security
camera when you purchase
a simply safe system at simplysafe.com
s-i-m-p-l-i s-a-f-e
dot com you'll get a 60-day risk-free
trial
so there's nothing nothing to lose all
right simply safe.com for your free
security camera today that's
simplysafe.com
all right manscaped everybody look at me
been on the road with the beard i could
use some of this right now
uh looking for the ultimate stocking
stuffers for
this holiday season i'm actually gonna
say stocking stuffers are the biggest
pain in the ass
okay you always forget it and then when
you do get something what if it's too
heavy it's going to rip the stocking
right off the little nail there
like you're in whoville this is the
perfect gift for you all right look no
further because our sponsors
manscapes manscape have the tools to
make you win this year's
stocking stuffer or white elephant
competition manscape is the only brand
dedicated to below the waist grooming
and hygiene products and great news
they just released their products across
europe canada and australia
a few their products that are prime
stocking stuffers this season are the
crop preserver
ball deodorant now that
nothing says i love you like letting a
loved one know that their balls stink
and you have the solution
on christmas or hanukkah kwanzaa
whatever you celebrate
the name speaks for itself crop reviver
ball toner
huh you want that youthful glow in your
sack
they got a spray on toner that will give
your balls a little slice of heaven
with their aloe vera and hazel
extract they should have said hazelnut
extract
crop mop ball wipes
you know your balls need so much
attention it's good the company finally
addressed it
crop mop ball wipes this is not a toupee
for your nuts
uh you never know when an opportunity
strikes you so you should always be
prepared
foot duster this is foot deodorant
designed to keep the stankiest feet
smelling fresh
uh shears 2.0 is a luxury four-piece
nail clip
clip kit i say [ __ ] nail kit
uh the weed whacker nose and ear hair
trimmer which prov
provides proprietary skin safe
technology to get rid of those nasty
nose hairs
let's not forget about the best trimmer
for your butt balls and body
the lawn mower 3.0 trimmer dude
you can't tell me bigfoot's not getting
this he's probably sick of hiding in the
woods he's going to get himself all
cleaned up and get a desk job
with the lawnmower 3.0 trimmer offers a
replaceable ceramic blade with advanced
skin safe technology which helps reduce
grooming accidents
that'll affect your whole mood in a date
if you got a [ __ ] cut on your balls
uh these formulations are all vegan
cruelty free
dye free sulfate free and paraben free
so you know their products are legit i
don't know what half that [ __ ] is get 20
off and free shipping at manscape.com
with the code bur
20 burr 2-0 whether it whether this is
for your partner
dad brother friend get them something
that they will actually use and it's
almost sure uh to get a laugh get twenty
percent off and free shipping at
manscape.com with birth two
bur two zero be the ballsiest gift giver
this year with man skate
there you go hey what's going on it's
bill burr and it's the monday morning
podcast for monday
uh december 10th 2012. how's it going uh
for those of you who follow me on
twitter
you guys know that i have a special
guest this week um and we're going to
get right to it
because he's already bugging me with his
[ __ ] giant shirt we have the
one and only michael rappaport from
every film that you've ever [ __ ] had
nice to uh nice to have you on here
you're reinventing the
podcast because you said podcast so your
accent you
p-a-w-d cast yeah yeah
and i'm talking [ __ ] about accents
that's the uh that's the boston podcast
i know
but i like that that's the boston accent
i know i got it
no i got it because a lot of people when
they do that you actually pick up on
that that it's that we say p-a-w
we say boston b-a-w like boston and
people always go where are you from when
i say you know i grew up outside of
boston then they go oh
boston uh it's like no dude boston yeah
like saw
with yeah b no i got you yeah i know i'm
not one to talk about accents
but i i like i like the boston accent i
like it
because it's more [ __ ] up than the new
york accent that's why i like just all
the pens
it all depends i have to adjust these
levels it is like apples and oranges but
i do like the i like the boston accent
and i like the chicago accent their [ __ ]
is
way out there yeah and that's one that i
can't even uh
duplicate like i can i haven't been out
to the midwest enough like in chicago to
even try and like
do a bad it sounds like everybody's
doing an snl character
the chicago accent is just it's just i
love it you like the chicago
i just like working class accents like
boston new york well what i think about
you is you've lived out here forever
and you never lost your accent yeah i
must have had the the voice coaches and
all that saying like
yeah michael if you want to work more in
this industry yeah they warned me
but you know all the actors that i
really admire
they never truly lose their accent so i
was like if they don't have to do it and
i'm
of course as good as them and i'm of
course referring to like the de niros
and pacinos because i'm you know when
you mention de niro pacino
rapaport it's like de niro rapaport
brando rappapo sometimes they put
daniro patino brando rappaport and
that's fine right that's fine
you don't get upset no i don't get upset
but you know i've i've lost it a little
bit here and there and you know you
don't you could tone it down you could
do variations on when you go back i
like because when i go back to boston
like uh and i
run into some people who really have it
hardcore yeah i like burst out laughing
going like especially when it's a
beautiful girl
yeah yeah massachusetts and that heinous
accent
like are you sure yeah they'll say stuff
like that and it's coming out of their
mouth and they sound like they're
[ __ ] like there's something they have
brain damage
yeah and there is those times where i'm
just like wow i
that i used to and i never thought i had
it that bad yeah i have some old
stand-up tapes that i will never show
anybody
oh where you could really hear it oh
dude i am brutal yeah
brutal like i would win an oscar like if
it was
like a boston accent how bad it was
right i still have it pretty bad yours
is good but
when we were working in boston yours
because we were playing
boss of course i was my my boston accent
was
it's pretty pretty well i was sound east
coast so yeah well i was the i was the i
was the black sheep of the family so i
was like he must have left boston so
yeah he went upstairs but yours was
yours was hard i was like because it was
you and you there was other boss of
people i was like people
there really got that [ __ ] down you know
people were really in their native their
native tongue
yeah no no i didn't get anything down i
just i was from there
right i don't do any uh i don't do any
work but just to let people know we did
a movie this uh this summer called the
heat
with uh sandra bullock and melissa
mccathy and the director of uh
bridesmaid
paul feig it's comedy r-rated comedy
bill's really funny in it curses a lot
everybody curses a lot and
this we're we're a dysfunctional family
yeah we all play
we all and we all play brothers which is
of course when i when i tweeted out that
you were going to be on the podcast here
and i was just saying if you have any
questions let me know and i knew it was
going to be a bunch of what are you guys
brothers the pigment thing and all that
red the redhead son son the sun cancer
twins
all that [ __ ] they they weren't even
that good and that's the thing they send
them to me like they're gonna make me
laugh and they think they're so [ __ ]
clever and it was basically
70 uh the exact same joke but there was
a couple uh
i should actually read the funny ones
what were some of the what were some of
the highlights
you want to hear some of these i love
the day sometimes i set myself up on
twitter to see like
if i'm gonna get some good stuff and
people make me laugh even if they're
insulting me i'll see if i can
[ __ ] you if you insult me on twitter by
the way you know i don't i don't respond
back
i might just retweet because you know my
kids i got kids and it's not it's just
what good does it do i used to when i
first got on twitter i would get into
arguments with people
oh you're making that day i know oh my
god the guy from true romance yeah i'm
i'm actually interacting yeah he told me
to [ __ ] off
and they read they retweet this [ __ ]
your mother and they
they put that on there all right well
this is a good one why did stupid fox
cancel his show the war at home so
that's a nice one they were a fan
they were a fan they were a fan politics
man politics
politics and show business just like
politics and politics
let's see what we got here anything good
uh do you think you were separated at
birth
that's funny that's all
we're going to discuss sunblock thought
you and him were the same guy
there's another one ask rap report if he
realizes he's white
yeah i love that just because you're
from brooklyn and you have an
appreciation for uh
a culture other than your own yeah um
where are we i know it's just gonna be
more this i'm not gonna waste time
[ __ ]
blowing through this stuff but uh what
was i going to ask you
i was going to get into this thing the
whole way this whole podcast you being
on the podcast came about
wasn't just that we you know were
working together was that
we both have dogs right and we i started
talking about you know the big thing is
curb your dog if you have a dog like in
new york city
i think that they were the first ones
came up with the uh cooper scooper super
scooper or pupa scooper where i was from
and uh yeah that basically to get the
dog [ __ ] off right
and then that became a thing because
when i was a kid if your dog took a [ __ ]
it just took a [ __ ]
right it was just outside it barely said
i have a license so now you're supposed
to pick up after it so i never owned a
dog in new york
but i own one out here and i always pick
up after her
and you had this interesting duality as
far as when and where you pick up after
your dog
yes well here's the deal okay i i grew
up i never had dogs
so when i actually got my first dog i
lived in los angeles and of course you
know you want to follow you got the dog
a license and
right you know pick up after the dog and
and i was good and
i would carry the [ __ ] bags and and i
would pick up the [ __ ] and then i had
two dogs so it would be
you know you'd have to bring like three
or four [ __ ] bags per trip right because
each dog who knows what's going to
happen
but the thing is then i
then i moved to los angeles then i moved
back to new york with my two dogs
and in new york this is where the what
kind of dogs about mutts two months
two months so two months uh and and but
this is where the conversation between
me and bill about
dog [ __ ] and [ __ ] bags got interesting
because i said
i don't use [ __ ] bags anymore now i'm
back living in los angeles and bill
there was a just a sense of judgment on
you don't use [ __ ] bags in l.a in l.a i
don't use [ __ ] bags
and the reason why here's the deal in
new york i use [ __ ] bags like
clean up all the the the door in new
york cause you're like easy no
no west coast no no no that's not why no
prejudice
no i would pick up the [ __ ] and then be
able to walk to the corner
and drop the [ __ ] bag in the garbage
pail
okay in los angeles there's not and so
in new york there's garbage cans on
every corner
there is yes there is even caddy corner
there's garbage cans sometimes they're
filled all the way to the top and the
garbage is spilling out but at least
it's the place to get rid of the [ __ ]
bag full of [ __ ] in los angeles
for those who are not familiar with los
angeles there are not garbage cans on
every corner
so therefore when you are walking your
dog
and two dogs when i made up my own rule
about this
you you pick up the dog crap i don't
keep saying [ __ ]
you pick up the door crap in the [ __ ]
bag
and then you carry it and you could be
walking three
four five six blocks
with it now i'm carrying i have two dogs
on a leash
medium-sized dogs 50 60 pound dogs with
two [ __ ] bags right
by my side it's not like you could take
the [ __ ] back and put it in your pocket
and then
dump it out like it's like like a like a
candy wrapper right
that's not cool to be have to walk
around with two shoes
it's not the picking up it's the
carrying of the ship it's the carrying
of it now i could change my rule and
pick up the [ __ ]
put it into ship eggs and then throw
that right on the side of the street
and then someone else has to deal with
it but a a person
but you should play devil's advocate
play it you
you got the two [ __ ] dogs
all right you live in a nice upstanding
neighborhood you're considered a good
citizen
of this of this not by anyone who knows
me all right
i appreciate that bill do your neighbors
like see like your dogs take shits
and you just walk like let me ask you
this yes so when you're in la if your
dog's taking a [ __ ] do you at least put
your head on the swivel and be like oh
there's a basket over there i will pick
this lump
no i i i do not buy [ __ ] bags anymore
mine i have zero tolerance i have a i
don't [ __ ] with [ __ ] bags anymore and
the reason why i don't [ __ ] with
shitbags anymore is because i'm not
walking around with bags of [ __ ] for
block and block and block and block
it's just not cool it's not it's
degrading
and here's how is it degrading to to
walk with a a
a steaming hot bag of [ __ ] for like you
don't want to hold it from underneath no
but
you know it's hanging but i got two dude
why do i have one dog
stanley died r.i.p stanley sorry to hear
that
okay she was old but but but you know
even now i have a big dog
dog takes big shits you know and in the
bag and then
i i i can't walk text cause you gotta
text when you're walking your dog that's
when you get good
yeah that's good text time when you're
walking your dog i can't walk the dog
who i
sometimes take off the leash she's
trained and then carry a [ __ ] back and
i'm just not doing it and i'll tell you
something i'll tell you something so
you say upstanding citizen and i'm like
this the game i'll refer to it as the
game the [ __ ] game
listen if someone if a dog shits on my
yard
i don't it's part of the game oh you
don't get mad if so
nope you [ __ ] on my yard it is what it
is
my dog shits in your yard it is what it
now sometimes there is a tinge of guilt
if i know that
it's it's because i know some of my
neighbors so i'll be like oh [ __ ] you
know
like there's a six-year-old there he's
probably going to wind up playing
stepping in it running and oh there's a
six-year-old girl there at least like
when your dog takes the [ __ ] do you
stand there defiantly like i know my
dog's taking a [ __ ] i'm not picking up
or do you pretend to be talking on the
phone and not notice it are you a worm
about it
or are you i'm a worm about it i'm not
gonna front listen there's sometimes
i'll feign like i'm bending over
and i'm doing something to pick it up or
if somebody goes hey your dog just went
to the
oh you know he's sick i i ran out of
[ __ ] bags you know like
he's a lie i i'm not gonna yeah cause
you but because because i've had
confrontations
one dude do people literally say hey
michael rappaport
that happened once dog took a [ __ ] one
because now now that you have
wait you've had fame for a while but
you're not some random they can't be
you can't believe what this [ __ ]
[ __ ] did you they do can't believe it
i will
accept that i will not argue that it's
part of the [ __ ] game
so i gotta turn this down man cause
we're [ __ ] getting into this i think
i got the levels too high
if you want to insult me criticize me
judge me on
my policies with [ __ ] bags fine it's not
a los angeles thing i love los angeles
i'm from new york
it's just you put a garbage can on every
corner this will go out the door
you got a problem with me put it on you
have demands
listen i'm not walking i'm not walking
more than a half a block with a [ __ ] bag
who's the most famous person you've seen
walking with the [ __ ] bag for a good six
blocks you ever just been driving around
and you'd be like oh there's uh mary
tyler moore sharing his [ __ ]
i've never seen have you ever seen
somebody with a [ __ ] bag
somebody famous no but i think that they
have like their assistant walks their
dog
maybe that's what your problem is dude
once you get famous dude you need like
an assistant i need to walk the dog i
need that text time i need to clear my
head i got two kids
get out of the house for a few minutes
and i do my thing but i will tell you
one time do your kids know that you
don't pick up your [ __ ]
unfortunately yes and i and i say you
know
don't don't this is a three-prong
problem yeah because it's just
and then it's creating other little kids
but i i explained to them the reason why
because if you in los angeles if you
carry that [ __ ] back you either have to
make it back to your house say you're 10
blocks away from your house
dude i live it every morning you walk
with a [ __ ] back eight nine ten blocks
you know ioma it's almost remember that
tom hanks movie where he was like
talking to the soccer ball
yeah like literally like it's to that
point and doesn't it disrupt once you
pick up the [ __ ] and you have the [ __ ]
bag
that's the only thing you're thinking
about and then sometimes you get so
relaxed
it's just like you forget that it's even
in your hand and it's like just dangling
it's not cool it gets to the point no
you know what it is when she takes a
[ __ ] horrific [ __ ] this is going to
be the [ __ ] podcast here by the way when
she takes one of those horrific shits
steamer that you can literally see
through the bag and then you're walking
with it and then some hot chick comes
jogging
you just you just feel like an [ __ ]
it's degrading man it's degrading and
that's my thing
i i had left degrading i've it's it is
i've had people say pick your [ __ ] up
you know i had one guy
my dog and i told this guy i shook his
hand afterwards my dog shot his yard
i kept walking i told him that the dog
is sick this guy's a prick anyway i i i
this when he first moved in the
neighborhood and i didn't know he was
much
why is he a prick because he called you
out or cause he no i respected that
we got into some other thing later he
called he cursed out
my kid and some other kids called them
really bad names and
it was bad was it because they weren't
picking up no it wasn't even that he was
just
you know one of those guys like it was
whatever but my dog shot in his yard he
some had a weird accent too
and and and and then he said something i
said the dog is sick or whatever
one of my two or three excuses i had i
kept going
this [ __ ] guy i was walking three
four blocks away
picked up the [ __ ] in a [ __ ] bag drove
up to me so he picked up the [ __ ] in a
[ __ ] bag and brought the [ __ ] back in
his car
i respected it and he came up to me in
your dog [ __ ] and he handed me the [ __ ]
bag and i said you know what
i respect that i took the [ __ ] i said
shake he didn't want to shake my answer
please please i shook his hand
and he went on you know and then i
dropped the [ __ ] back right you're
acting like you're you're noble that
this guy had to go pick up your [ __ ] and
be like you know what i respect that
i respect that you just picked up my
dog's [ __ ]
and [ __ ] it's good depends on what
you feed them if you don't eat if you
feed them the human food then their
shit's as healthy as our [ __ ]
it's fine it's good for the grass but
let's have you noticed that by the way
what anything can take a [ __ ] on your
yard and it'll make the grass greener
except for a human being and i've shat
on my own yard
okay we gotta get into this
that's my [ __ ] bag i apologize for the
cough no no
listen man i [ __ ] i bought these
[ __ ]
cigars and i put them in the [ __ ]
humidor and i had it turned up too
[ __ ] high
and it [ __ ] up the cigars like this
that gets as [ __ ] acceptable there's
like [ __ ] little bug eggs in there
and if it's up too high they like hatch
i don't know what i don't know what i
have
i think i think i got a virus in me it's
it's gradually
this is the most disgusting first oh no
no that's good
i don't want to discuss people i'm not
i'm not like one of these people with
the
you know who likes to talk about [ __ ]
all right so on a shooting a scale of
one to ten
yeah as far as your your upstanding
citizen count 10 being the best
one being like i can't wait for that
[ __ ] to move out of this
neighborhood
where where are you aside from dog stuff
i'm a good neighbor i consider myself a
good neighbor i i do that's like manson
say
aside from [ __ ] uh getting people
killed i'm a good driver no no aside
from my dog
my dog is harmless the dog couldn't hurt
a fly listen
my house got broken into the [ __ ] dog
was sleeping it said on the police
report it said the dog was sleeping
you freaked me out about that you were
home and somebody came in and just
like the boldness of that just came into
your house at night
took like whatever laptop or some
[ __ ] took stuff
and my dog didn't wake up cops come
dog [ __ ] bolts out there cops pull
the pepper spray no
no don't don't pepper spray him right
when he had his moment to shine
to bark attack do something he was
sleeping
you know i made this reference the other
day you know what it's like he's like
that dude bobby in saturday night fever
driving around the crowd where were you
guys i was looking for you
i was looking forward exactly i would i
would have done something
so bobby you actually made me i got it
they [ __ ] got gus
in saturday fever remember they beat up
gus that's why they went back and got
them
oh that's right i've only seen it a
couple of times senate fever i know i
know that's a big one for you for you
guys you guys in brooklyn
you're from brooklyn by the way i'm from
manhattan you're from manhattan people
can make that mistake i went to school
in brooklyn i have a lot of friends in
brooklyn i have a lot of affiliations in
brooklyn
but i'm from manhattan you know people
you go to brooklyn they know you i got
yeah i got a brooklyn pass well let me
ask you this
as a uh before we get into this [ __ ] are
we done with the [ __ ] topic here
i'm fine with it you brought it up you
bro i'm comfortable with it you were
fascinated by it i
i'm comfortable with my stance you know
because you know what it is i have such
a [ __ ] need to be liked
i got when we when we come back after
this uh the community you're talking
about you need to be liked
i'm gonna talk about that and how i just
found out from my [ __ ] neighbor how
loud i am
oh okay i had no i have that problem too
okay i think it's an east coast thing
we're just loud all right here we go
um the man great system everybody uh
this holiday season
think the man great what is the man
great you ask or maybe you didn't ask
but the copy did
um they're 100 made in america cast iron
grilling grates
that are revolutionizing the way people
grill named one of 2012's best grilling
accessories by
men's health magazine man greats are
perf the perfect gift this holiday
season
it's the worst read ever it's really
good click on the man great banner
on uh billboard.com for their 1999
holiday special do you get one for free
yeah they hook me up they've given me
two so far so if you want one i can give
it to you why not i use it they're
awesome
it's basically you know like when you
have like a little hibachi yeah and they
give you those little
that little [ __ ] grate yeah it's like
for a grilled cheese sandwich i'm ready
this thing you put it in you put their
system on it's the big thick ones like
at a steak house you can really like
mark up your seats
you get more heat on it it's it's it
actually makes the food taste 100
sounds good every monday morning podcast
order comes with a heavy duty grilling
brush
again that's the man great grill
enhancement system order today
at billberg.com the guy who invented
it's going to be [ __ ] standing next
to george foreman in the
i got a 100 million dollar line exactly
george foreman got a lot of money off
those girls and that's one of those
things i wish that i came up with
let me let me do the stamps.com and
we're done with the advertising uh
stamps.com everybody would you love to
have the post office
in your house rather than having to go
there why wouldn't you when the holidays
are almost here you don't have time to
go to the post office traffic parking
it'll be packed and everyone's mailing
holiday gifts
and packages thank you so what do you do
you go to stamps.coms instead
with stamps.com you can avoid all the
hassle of going to the post office
during the busy holiday season
everything you would do with the post
office you can do right from your desk
you can buy and print official us
postage
using your own computer and printer
print postage for any letter or package
the instant you need it
then the mailman picks it up it's so
easy i use stamps.com to send out all my
dvds every weekend while the weekends
that i'm working i should say
uh you should use it too right now get
this special offer when you use my last
name bur burr
get a no-risk trial plus 110 bonus that
includes a digital scale
and up to 55 dollars in free postage
even if you don't use it you get 55
dollars in stamps
uh don't wait go to stamps.com before
you do anything else click on the
microphone at the top of the homepage
and type in verb b-u-r-r that's
stamps.com
enter burr all right back to the podcast
let's do it um
so today right we saw bruce springsteen
by the way
the other night down in anaheim oh i
thought you saw him around here no no no
no sorry that's cool
yeah and i've never seen him and i was
one of those guys going dude i don't get
it all he does is sing about jersey but
like so many people i know
who work borderline did he do his
southern accent
because he's from jersey but he's does a
southern accent sometimes which is weird
to me
he didn't do that do you know what i'm
talking about i'm just you know he's he
does like a southern accent but he's
from jersey oh yeah you know
what he's like he's the common man yeah
you're the common man but you're from
jersey
yeah yeah i like go ahead go ahead i
don't want to [ __ ] on bruce
he went and i was down there like all
right man you know all right
i was gonna say born to be wild born to
run or whatever i'll listen to this [ __ ]
dude i gotta tell you something man the
fact that i ever think that i gave a
performance after seeing what that guy
did
dude four songs in i'm already blown
away he's blown away bands that are in
their 20s and 30s that i've seen just
[ __ ] killing
his voice sounds unreal goes out to the
middle of the crowd he's standing on
this stage out there
people are going [ __ ] nuts and then
he just lays back
into the crowd and crowd surfs like 70
rows
that's cool up to the as the band keeps
playing that's crazy and right as he
gets onto the stage
boom they go right into the closing
verse dude that's
that's encore yeah that's you know
that's somebody closing out a great
concert yeah it was his fourth song
that's crazy and and it didn't peak
there it just kept he wore me out dude i
was sitting how long did he go for
three and a half hours of that energy
yeah that's because
he is no joke dude it was it was it was
sick
and the thing about that that i love so
much is that he doesn't have to do three
and a half hours
he loves to perform totally you totally
get your money's worth like that
he was like whether you like it or not
like bruce that guy i could i got just
like longer than schindler's list
what the [ __ ] bruce i gotta go man i
gotta take my dog out to take a [ __ ] you
know
every time like i was i'm so old like my
back's killing me and [ __ ]
and they do that [ __ ] where they they
have like uh they hit the final note of
the song and weinberg's doing the simple
watch and they play playing a chord and
you think he's gonna be like
thanks a lot anaheim you were great and
he always just goes
one two three four and they go into them
i'm like oh my god that's crazy like you
just
kept thinking that this guy couldn't get
uh dude and it's [ __ ]
anaheim yeah one of the cheesiest like
just like
he said it not me that's bill talking
about anaheim dude it doesn't even look
real right i think back in the day when
they had like all the orange groves
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah i've been
some sort of personality it's just one
[ __ ] strip mall
after another right it looks like a
giant like it's disneyland down there
right yeah
yeah like there's no there isn't that
feeling of any sort of culture right
either way
right and he's down there acting
performing like he's in giant stage
that's cool
yeah i respect that man that's yeah so
anyway so today
that [ __ ] born to run song which i
never never was into so i'm up in the
bathroom and i'm singing it but i'm
doing different lyrics and i'm singing
to nia
and it's all vulgar and i did were you
born to come
no no no i was just saying i was
starting off saying
uh i was just singing about what a great
guy i was and that nia doesn't
appreciate it and all this [ __ ] that i
did but in the cadence of born to run
yeah and then somehow there was
something about banging you in the ass
just it was really it was that's cool
it was really vulgar that's cool then it
goes um
like banging your ass like maybe hey
like you know i don't need a christmas
gift i'll bang you in the air she'll
never let me do it baby we can
do no yeah but she'll never let me do
that yeah yeah so i was singing that you
got it
and i got all the way to the top
loudest [ __ ] hell so i walk out of
the bathroom i didn't realize my bedroom
window was open
i go hey niagara do you like that bruce
springsteen impression
and before she could answer i heard
somebody just in a talking voice goes
no oh i was like oh [ __ ] it was your
neighbor
yeah and i started thinking like holy
[ __ ] how much have they been hearing
how loud am i and then nia
i kept wanting nia to make me feel
better but she just goes you know you're
you're you're loud yeah you're there's
times i pull up in the car and i hear
you on the phone
and it's making me like really like
self-conscious like [ __ ] i'm i'm that
loud
and i felt bad until you [ __ ] come
and i'm like you come and i and i
you hit the buzzer and i pick it up i'm
like hello and you start screaming
derrick
cheater that's right like loud as [ __ ]
that's right maybe it's just an east
coast well
as far as upstanding citizens and
loudness i i i've come to terms with the
fact that my neighbors
know everything about me if they wanted
to like you know
start a scandal on me or you know they
know
my whole life because yeah i i got this
buddy of mine back he's big giant yankee
fan so we have these at
paul versus we have these epic [ __ ]
uh
arguments about sports where i'm just
like i got him on speakerphone
and i'm yelling like we're in a crowded
bar i can't imagine i i feel bad for my
neighbors
and what they've heard the i i know
they've heard me doing it do my
neighbors on this side have kids and the
stuff that i say [ __ ] all the time
it's just like she doesn't give me dirty
looks so
but i look at it like she has a toddler
and i can never hear her kid
well if you never hear the little snotty
nosed loud mouth kids screaming and
crying she probably never hears
you should ask her see that's what i
need to hear me you ever hear me say
[ __ ] or [ __ ] you or because i don't want
to offend your kids and
you should just ask her i don't know i
think that would get uh
it get weird but whatever you have to be
mean to say yo i still it takes a lot
for me to be embarrassed at this point
although you know just in general you
become immune to humiliation when you
get into this [ __ ] like every audition
you go into and you eat your balls after
a while yeah
you just don't feel it anymore yeah but
that i literally got uh
that made me feel i felt i was
embarrassed i was like wow she
she heard all of that and like just the
uh the way she said no to
right was this was not the first time
you heard my loud voice she's
yeah she's just a nap you just opened
the window up for her
to open the window literally for her to
get involved with the conversation i was
fantasizing about all these
cool comebacks that i wish i said but in
the end i just had to realize like you
know what she was right
yeah she was right she was right yeah i
i i've come to terms with it i got a
loud speaking voice and but i'm in my
house i'm not
bringing it down so you hear what you
hear and that's it
but i turn music up i got a pool and i
turn the fountains on when i'm there
it's not like it's not our fault that
[ __ ] houses are two feet
like i could literally take a running
leap out my if i could leap through my
bedroom window and i could
land on the roof of the house next door
right i know we're on top of each other
not the house i mean it's slamming to
the side but you know what i mean
you'd be there i would be there i would
definitely be there so this is uh
some sports questions i'm trying to i
know people want to know about your
movies and [ __ ] but i just figured yeah
yeah yeah that you've answered
all of that i'll answer whatever zillion
times all right well before i go into
more sports [ __ ]
okay we haven't started but i always end
up talking sports yeah like
you know right out of the gate dude you
were in one of the greatest movies
of of my life uh true romance
and uh i was wondering like you were
basically roommates with brad
was brad pitt brad pitt at that point or
was he just about to be almost brad pitt
at that point like he was
he had done like thelma and louise he
had done um
the movie with robert redford he he had
done stuff he'd done california
and you know he was he wasn't the
superstar but you knew that he was going
to be
that he was very well liked and and you
know there was
he was he was about to be brad pitt so
you it was you know that you were just
saying yeah yeah yes good looking son of
a [ __ ] with his abs
no no no he was he was he was real he
was totally cool and and
um you know the thing about true romance
was that first of all the script was so
great when you read the script it just
read you were like
you know quentin tarantino scripts they
just read so easy and you're just like
laughing and like what the [ __ ] and it
was so irreverent and so
you know every i'd say about 95
of what wound up in romance was was
written like it's so
actor friendly like it's hard to score
it up and so
you know i had heard like you know
initially was like okay christian slater
and patricia arquette and patricia
arquette i had just seen in
sean penn's movie called indian runner
right that was like one of the first
things she did she was great in that i
was like oh this is gonna be dope and
you know christian slater was like you
know right at that time he was it was
perfect and then
you heard oh well gary oldman's playing
um
whatever the pimp the pimp i can't
remember the character's name and
oh that's cool and then val kilmer is
playing elvis really so so you you were
already i wasn't cashing like i was i
had been going
in for another part i had been going in
for for for uh one of the mobsters
and um and and actually actually i
actually i got cast as one of the
mobsters
as one of the younger mobsters so i
would i was like kind of like
oh you know you would have been in that
scene with uh the classic scene
i would have been in there yeah around
there
and then so then you heard like yeah
watkins playing the mobster holy [ __ ]
and then dennis hopper's playing as that
holy [ __ ] and and samuel and i'm 24
years old
at this point i had done zebra head a
little part in poetic justice just to
meet tupac
i was like it was like i just wanted to
meet him like i and
yeah and then a little part in in uh a
movie another
movie and then and then true romance so
i mean i was
such a fan of all these guys and i was
so sort of
excited everybody was and but how big
was tupac by the time uh
he was he was tupac for he was doing
poetic justice he it was he was
he was at he was like a star and because
i thought he kind of came out and
he was with uh who's that guy the humpty
dance guys in like 90 89 90 and yeah
then he broke out on his own like 91-92
i would think he was still like on the
rise he was on
he wasn't what he became like he became
this iconic i love to know this was
after juice
i loved his music he wasn't the star
that he became like
after you know he was with death row and
he really took it to the next level but
he was
he was big i mean he was you know and i
i thought he was
i thought juice his performance in this
movie juice was just like
it was incredible right and i was just i
at that time i mean i'm still a huge fan
of movies and huge fan of actors but
like
at that time like i would become
enamored with people's performances and
i liked his music and
i had a funny kind of relationship
following him because i was friends with
jada pinkett and she kept telling me
before he did anything my friend tupac
he's going to be a big star too and i
had heard his name and then he came out
with
humpty dance and he came out with that
you know that one verse on
digital underground and then you know
then of course his solo album and then
juice and i was just like damn this this
guy is special and
so to do that it was john singleton who
was just off of boys in the hood
and um janet jackson when janet jackson
was like james
dude you worked with everybody it was
your first first by the time you're 24
you were with
i was about every icon out there yeah
and it meant a lot to me like i mean i i
get excited now but like at the time i
was so i was young and i was like i was
like
really excited so true romance and it
was quentin tarantino
who had done reservoir dogs um natural
born killers had come out
i think but he didn't direct us he
didn't direct it he wrote it
and i had met quentin originally at the
sundance film festival because the year
that
reservoir dogs was there was the same
year that zebrahead was there and that
was a big deal for me it was a big deal
for him he was nobody
right i was nobody i was really nobody
and you know that was a really exciting
time for independent filmmaking so
you know the script was being passed
around and it could hollywood felt like
a smaller community at that time so
everybody was talking about
true romance and i got cast as one of
these mobsters and this one was in it
and that one was in it
and then oh see they cast you as one
casting is one of the mobsters so what
happened
so then they in the script dick richie
the character i want to play was written
as a black
it was written as dick richie black
young actor blah blah blah blah
so they were looking at young uh young
active black actors right
he was just written that way um and then
they they
weren't finding them and um tony scott
the great tony scott rest in peace
great guy so much fun to work with um
they they called me and they mary vernu
who was a casting assistant who's now a
huge casting director and
um oh man i got to fix this because the
other casting director i can't remember
her name that's all right
i never remember no but they gave me
about 20 names they gave me a big break
anyway but i remember i got the word
that from my agent that mary vernou was
like
she thinks you're dick richie and you
should play that and it was very true
i never considered the part because i
wasn't even brought in she was like the
way you are and i was like that like i
was like
looking for my big break and you know
and i was just really sort of wide
eyed and yeah i don't know how actors do
that's the hardest thing ever i don't
know how you guys do it
what it's so much easier as a stand-up
well yeah you're sitting there doing an
hour-long commercial
that's you're special right people of
you just do it enough eventually
that's how i i finally got little little
parts that i've been getting lately was
just going through that
the [ __ ] that you guys do like i've done
a couple of pilots yeah and like the
second the pilot
is over you know i'm going to go go tell
jokes so these other guys are like well
unemployed again and yeah i don't know i
don't know how you do that it's true
i don't want to no no it's cool and then
i i want to talk about because you said
something when we were working together
about the stand-up thing which is like
you're independent if you're good at it
which you are and you're successful at
it it's you have a
you're never unemployed like i i
beautiful thing i don't have
that level of strength to do
uh to try and make it just as a then
well i mean i had a passion for stand up
but just just sit there and be like all
right i'm gonna [ __ ] wake table
[ __ ] that and i'm gonna get a bit part
and be in this movie
this giant production and then you know
every [ __ ] movie you see
there's like a hundred whatever about 40
actors yeah work on that yeah there's
like two people that
continue on exactly and then then maybe
somebody
in in the other whatever 38 gets
something and then everybody else goes
back to [ __ ] waiting tables right you
were just
you were in a movie which is the biggest
thing ever to everybody in your hometown
stuff and they i don't know that they
understand how
[ __ ] hard that is yeah it's tough
it's tough
it's so just uh it the the um
i'm not saying like you know it's
supposed to dig in a ditch it's not
physically hard but
emotionally it's hard emotionally to go
from that
it's emotionally it is hard yeah to then
[ __ ] going back to waiting the tables
and uh i don't know and just knowing
you're good enough
right just just having it and then yeah
and no you're going to be and it's being
proved because you
you got a part yeah but it might not pay
the bills much longer than
you know you know when you're when you
you could be like are you if you were a
quarterback and you came out your first
start you threw 300 yards
and for some inexplicable reason you sit
on the bench again
for two [ __ ] years like tom brady
crazy like that's like brady's thing
like he was just sitting there sitting
there
right you know yeah it's being an actor
the emotional highs and lows are
are are tough but i could never do it
it's it's
it sucks it's the worst part of it
because that's so much of it it's so
much does it seems like it sucks that's
why it always makes me laugh
when when when actors they'll be like
stand up has this weird sort of like
it's
respected and they also look at you like
you're slapping yourself in the head
with a rubber chicken
where it's like it's it is obnoxious
just ask my neighbor
it's [ __ ] obnoxious but then like
there is this respect for it but like oh
the balls it takes to get on that like
i i feel like there is a lot of
humiliation but the level
i just couldn't handle the [ __ ]
stress like i would be doing a movie
god willing and i would just be thinking
the whole time as i'm doing it's like
i have to be so [ __ ] unreal in this
thing or else i go back
to applebee's [ __ ] that like i i don't
know how they do it
it's tough you got that's why when
people ask me if anybody
they you know people always say what do
you what do you need to be to what do
you need to do to be in this business
and i always say you have to
it has to be something you have to do
it can't be something that you kind of
want to do i might
if you this business you will if it's
not something that you
have to do if it's intrinsically in you
that you have to do it
stop don't even try to do it because if
there's too much
it takes too much out of you you have to
do it it has to be something that's
within you
it's like if you were a writer like what
do i have to do to be a writer right
keep going keep and then if just because
you're not on
writing on you know the sopranos you if
you you have to
it has to be like something that's
organic just like like i think you just
have to have that that
psycho once you start down the road
there's no way i'm stopping
no matter how many times like i did you
know i got to tell you what's
crazy is as i know uh a couple of comics
throughout the years they're these
legendary guys who never got beyond
doing open mics or doing the occasional
spot
and they [ __ ] bomb 98 like
bomb like quit the business bomb
and they've stuck with it for 20 25
[ __ ] years
and you see like all these funny people
that you run into on the road they'll
say like dude like as much as i'm
[ __ ] on some of the stuff people
right on twitter there's people out
there that write really funny [ __ ] like
right and i think god damn that's
funnier than half the [ __ ] great
right but you you know try going on
stage oh no dude i could never do it i
can never do it
because it's the whole fear of bombing
and then you see this guy just night
after night after night
basically living the horror that
everybody does right and he and he just
keeps
[ __ ] right back and i always look at
those guys that's like dude if you could
take that stick tuitiveness
right and actually apply it to something
you're good at right there
you'd be great yeah there would be no
stopping you right that's [ __ ] up
yeah [ __ ] up it is but anyways let's
go back because i know people probably
upset that okay okay i got out off of
the
so jerome is so so i mean just this cast
was compiled so anyway so on a saturday
they were they needed to cast this part
like i was like a week or two weeks away
from shooting so on a saturday
which is unusual for show business and
in general to do anything on a saturday
because it's
[ __ ] saturday you know show business
they take all of december's off
yeah the fourth of july is like a
three-week holiday you know
like this business like every september
is jewish holidays holiday in this
business
so for them to do something on a
saturday there was a necessary you know
like there was an urgency
so i go in there and they're like you
know we feel like you're you're this guy
who you are
just reading that and and it was with me
tony scott and the casting directors and
i went through all the dick richie
scenes and they will and i and i said to
them because i i
once that door opened and i was like i
once i started thinking about tomorrow i
was like this
i love this part i love this character i
i remember i said to them don't let me
leave
um until i get it right you know and i
went in and i kept reading and told you
and you knew to say that at 24. because
it wasn't i wasn't in the hospital right
it wasn't any hustle that's i like like
now you could say that that's like oh
that's a smart thing to say like i just
because i once i locked into the to the
idea of me doing it i was like i had
blinders on
right when i was younger i would go in
there with blinders on that's another
like i would be like yo i'm going in
here i'm
getting this [ __ ] i'm doing this [ __ ]
and that's it and
and but it was what you're talking about
that's psycho focus yeah
it was that's what i had because it was
really it was you know it was like i
wanted it and it was it was right there
so i went in there i did it
i did a good job and i remember i
remember
one thing is that behind me like when i
went to go set up in the room
all the people that had been cast their
head shots were were sitting behind me
so it was like christopher walken
samuel jackson gary oldman all their
head shots like wow to play in this part
i remember
seeing that and i was just like you know
trying not to pay attention to it but i
remember walking over to the thing and
like seeing all them and i was like i
gotta [ __ ] do this i gotta get this
[ __ ]
right and um you know and for and then
they they called me like
two or three days later and and they
said you got the part and it was like
the character in the movie because it
was like you got the part i got the part
and
i just was so happy and and and then you
know i remember i went to a a rehearsal
was me and christian slater and patricia
arquette and patrice arquette was fine
at that time she's [ __ ] i had a huge
question me too
and she was beautiful and she was sexy
and really sweet and i was tripping out
i was like she's
fine and i just saw her in indian runner
and christian slater was like a part of
my youth
watching him so and i'm just starting to
be in the show business and
you know i had done a few things wasn't
he kind of your age too because he
started so young
he might have been a little older a
little older maybe not but i mean he was
christian slater he was a huge star
so i'm like tripping out and they're
like you know yeah you know like we're
like having this like bonding sessions
and we're like
i don't know we go out to eat and we're
like eating lunch and i'm like what the
[ __ ] am i doing here you know we're
reading scenes and it's tony scott and
he directed all these movies
and tony scott was just such a
tony scott the way he treats actors and
and the way he treated me at that time
was a big thing because
i was low man on the totem pole at least
i looked at myself like that and
you know but i was also had ideas and
thoughts about the character and he was
so
open right and and and some things he
would say great great do that something
saying i don't do that but he gave me a
voice and it was the first time where i
felt like
the first time i had only done four or
five things not like i've been trying to
do it because treating you like you
actually that you were pro like you know
what you were doing
yeah your ideas were worth listening to
exactly and some of them he liked and
some of them he didn't and
and but it really gave me confidence to
go forward like yeah i have a say in
these things and
he just was so positive and so much
energy
and and so enthusiastic every day and
his energy would supersede everybody on
the crew and he just was the uh
like you know the guy that i actually
was such a huge fan of was devastated
when he passed was chris penn chris penn
what was it like hanging you got to
because you
he was fun you you were in that that
final show yeah i've seen what you were
like yeah covering up and everything he
was great chris
and you know what what the day this goes
out if i'm going to i'm going to send
you a picture you could tweet with this
i really i found these cool pictures
from on the set oh that's great yeah i
would love that i'll send it to you like
you know like personal pictures that i
that i took
but chris penn tom sizemore and these
guys were like tom seismer was in
everything at the time
chris penn these were like dudes you
know and they were in a lot of [ __ ] and
i'm like with them and they're like
treating me like i'm one of them and
chris penn and
seismo they're like regular dudes chris
penn you know rest in peace also
he was just a sweet guy there was a
reservoir dogs like anniversary
dvd that i watched with this buddy of
mine derosa and uh
it had all of them like telling stories
yeah and chris penn's stories were just
like he could just see like he was just
that that
hanging out yeah he's a sweet guy yeah
yeah just sweet
so fun like he i always felt like the
way he he did
i loved him in reservoir dogs and i
actually went at close range
oh yeah and i went on this whole like
chris penn
tear yeah that anything he was in he did
some obscure movie
not obscure but it was one with harvey
keitel i can't remember what it was he
was somehow
his landlord or something i just
remember him running up the side of the
house trying to see if
kaitel was in there i can't remember
what the name of the movie was but this
is back when like blockbuster video yeah
i would i'd be going there like every
day and on this keitel
it was i just like reservoir dogs was
like ground zero for yeah and every
actor in there
i just went like off shoot and just find
all their stuff just like watching all
of that
and i became uh not like i stopped i was
just such a huge fan of that guy was uh
were they like hilarious they were just
hilarious and fun and
and and warm and big personalities and
you know victor argo he's another guy
passed away victor argo was one of the
mobsters he was in taxi driver
yeah he he was he was the guy in the in
the store when tech when
when travis shoots the guy when he tries
to rob the bodega you [ __ ] need to be
in a lot of scores he's in mean street
so i'm like bugging i mean
i'm bugging out that i'm working and
then samuel jackson
sam's treating me like he knows me right
you know and and i'm tr you know and val
kilmer is there and like i walk into the
makeup trailer and val kilmer is like
doing his elvis makeup and he's talking
in the elvis voice finding the character
gary oldman i remember having a
conversation it was crazy you're sitting
next to val kilmer who's doing elvis
it's crazy i'm tripping out i'm tripping
i'm literally like tripping and then
brad pitch
what did you do how did you
how did you not feed into that and go oh
my god i'm not worthy to be here how did
you keep yourself settled
this is becoming like inside the actor's
studio no well what i would do and what
i what i always do
still to this day when i work with
somebody like when i worked with you i
had to like get myself together
shut up no but you know what but you
know it's the same thing like my ego
actually entertained that for half a
second no i was on premium blend
maybe it was a thrill for him for at the
time at the time i used to
what i would do it i would i would enjoy
and
and be a fan when it was time to be a
fan i would never invade space or talk
to them about any i never would go up to
somebody and
and and sort of do what i'm doing to you
right now yeah i would never do that
man i remember me and my friend kevin
corrigan who winded playing the young
gangster
and we had worked together on my first
movie zebra head and we had worked
together on something else and
we were both like he got cast now we're
friends now
and i always look to kevin like he's a
real actor he's really good
you know he's been in tons of stuff he's
on he's on twitter we could tweet out
kevin
and and and we saw christopher walken in
in his wardrobe for the first time
by the craft service and kevin like
kevin would probably put
christopher walken as his number one
like i love christopher walker but i
would go like deniro is my number one
right but and kevin was just like and i
was like yo you got to go talk to him
i'm hyping him up go talk to a man like
yo you're like him go talk to him
and i remember he went over and talked
to him and like the conversation he'd
tell it better was kind of anti-climatic
because you know chris is bugged out
chris is so much more funnier than you
would think because but
at the time he was younger so he really
had that spooky look
and then that dark black hair and he has
the he had the wardrobe on so he had the
suit on with this long
um trench coat was his character vincent
oh it wasn't vincent vega that's what
was
the blonde it was that uh corality or
i don't remember he was the antichrist
he was the antichrist reincarnated
but i remember seeing him by craft
service by the by the truck and i was
like oh [ __ ] and
i mean it was just it was just such an
exciting time and gandolfini was in our
boat gandolfini was no that was his
first thing
right so he was even less than he had
never acted in a movie before like he
had done stage and
so he was really nervous he was really
freaking out
so he was playing the mobster and i
remember being there watching that scene
with him in patricia rk
and i'm just i would i would go to this
this is how you hang out oh yeah we'd go
to the set
just to just to go just to watch it like
the scene
with christopher walken and dennis opera
i was there watching it [ __ ] you yeah i
was watching in a minute it was a small
see it was a set
and it was a small little as as that
whole thing was yes
you were just sitting there going this
is this is crazy crazy yeah you knew
that was the only that was the only
movie that i've ever done
where you i i could say and i have a
pretty good track record this is the
only movie i've ever done i knew it was
going to be great
right to all the movies that i've done
highs lows good or bad whatever i
i we you knew it was special what did
now when when they would go i gotta ask
some
geek questions go ahead whatever all
right so when they would say cut after
they did a run through with the scene
would there be any laughing and joking
around or was it it was quite
serious it was it was it wasn't serious
like i'm taking myself seriously but i
think the tone of the scene because it
was serious
you know and then i remember a couple
times the line would get messed up
and you know there'd be a little bit of
giggling and tony you know i was behind
the monitor
right you know being super quiet and
literally saying to myself i can't
[ __ ] believe i'm here like tripping
out right because we all when you read
that scene that was word for word you
knew that scene you knew what it was
going to be
and just to hear them um i don't think i
had headphones on listening to it but
you could hear them
you know just to hear them and be around
it like you knew you were watching
something special like i
remember feeling like this is something
special and then when you see the scene
you know
like i like i was there like i remember
sitting there like watching it like this
is special you know and
and you feel as they each time they did
it a little different or
did they pretty pretty they had their
choices down they had their choices now
walking fluctuates a little bit
um but i think i think the scene was so
well written this is like
almost 20 years ago but the scene was so
well written
you didn't need to really once you made
your you're locked in you locked in
because it was just the right so many
moments
in that scene i love when walken clasps
his hands together
like a please don't make me whatever he
says yeah it's been a while since i've
seen it but
that that point where uh hopper
just like you know can i have one of
those chester fields and he's just like
you know what i'm going out [ __ ]
swinging
and when he finishes the story
he sees that look on his face where he's
like preparing himself yeah i'm gonna
get killed
yeah and it was just uh i i don't know
it's just one of the greatest scenes
it really is it was it really is special
it's special and and and you knew it was
going to be special and when they got
cast you knew
it was going to be great and how long
did it take them to shoot it like they
probably had a whole afternoon
or maybe the whole day like but they
might have had the whole afternoon
because
the thing about the scene there's not
much other than the acting there's not
much
logistically going on so just not
sitting there in that little trailer
yeah so
like technically it might have been a
whole day i i know i was there for a few
hours where did they shoot that
it was on a sound stage i don't want to
say it wasn't warner brothers
it was a sound stage i mean i don't
think it was warner brothers i can't
remember exactly where but it was
it was a stage i feel like it was culver
city-ish but
sony it might have been sony i think it
was sony i think it was sony
culver city so it was cool man it was
exciting i had to watch that again
immediately because i also like uh now
that i've been out in la here for like
five years i
actually like the same way i like
watching old movies about new york city
yeah
and seeing stuff that's still standing
there [ __ ] that changed i'm starting to
get like that for like la out here
like to go to the locations sometimes
yeah i'll actually do that like it bums
me out that where they shot uh reservoir
dogs right out in eagle rock
right and exist anyway right and i might
i just want to at least is the alley
still there
right where they pull the cop out of the
trunk right like
i'm a geek i love that stuff sports
stadiums and i'm a geek for like there's
like
there's probably 20 like guy movies yeah
that i would like i don't give a [ __ ]
about you know you know what women want
i don't know yeah
yeah they shot that but you know like if
there's a place where they shot good
fellas yeah if there's a place
i'm like reservoir dogs like the typical
hacky guy list
yeah of film there's no left turn on the
still the same way in my film
in the films that i like but uh me
neither but um
let's uh i want to talk to you something
about about hoop real quick unless you
had something more to add no no i mean
all i could say is it was a great
experience it was everything that you
would imagine
everybody was was great and i mean in
brad pitt it just was
it was special it was a special special
film to be a part of and it was a
special time for me
you know it was just a good it was a
suspect yeah you were in one of those
rare movies but before i described that
you know two people continue on the rest
you were in one where there was like it
seemed like 10 like everybody
yeah worked out of that in fact one of
the guys
who played uh in the scene uh
the walking scene with hopper uh the guy
who's over at the fridge
he speaks in a town yeah paul been
victor he's a good friend of mine yeah
he he was in um
he's in tons of stuff he was in what the
the wire he was in the wire yeah yeah
he's in day works all the time yeah and
he's wondering he was in there
and he was in the scene but he's one of
those guys he would have been back in
the day when blockbuster video was still
around
he'd be one of those guys that you
gradually like who's this guy keep
running this guy
and then you just you'd figure how the
[ __ ] do you how the [ __ ] back in the day
did you figure out what other movies
they did before
internet imdb before imdb you just had
to like
muscle it through that would be for good
conversation maybe oh you'd buy like
that book
you'd buy the book look at something
yeah but you wouldn't even be able to
keep up the update
because people you have to have a
conversation oh he was in this and you'd
call friends and now you could just
text and imdb having that conversation
the other day like
the the art of conversations and
figuring things out is gone because you
could just be like hold on and you look
at your phone and you got
every even thinking now on the on the
new the new download on the iphone where
they have like the the uh
that that gps thing right which is great
now you don't have to look down at the
phone
right you can just sit there mindlessly
make a right now it's crazy here
that i don't mind but sometimes like you
know like oh what was he in and you
could kind of like oh yeah he was in
that but you just get it all taken away
from imdb
now it's great yeah and it gets rid of
the debates and then yeah but you're 20
exactly 20 bucks says he was in that
movie then it would get resolved six
weeks later yeah
but now you can't even get to the bet
now so
speaking of betting i've got we got to
talk sports okay um
this is a [ __ ] question here that
what is it that i want about the next i
got i gotta ask
what about that thing you were saying to
me about red aurabac you heard that you
know
what was it you said that no you said
that you heard it and i was like i don't
know that's your guy
like say that i heard you heard that he
had a bungalow in west hollywood
and i was like that's a big scale you
should break that you know what i know
where this is coming from what this is
coming from you being a knicks fan
and you have two little championship
banners that have to be turning yellow
at this point they've been hanging up
there so [ __ ] long
yes that's true all right now i wasn't
gonna drop in like that okay
but you did say something about red or
back having a bungalow in west hollywood
and there was a whole scandal no i
didn't i thought it was i understand
it's the jealousy somebody brought that
up to me i thought it was
probably another sad ass [ __ ] knicks
fan i i was surprised i was like how
could red aurabac have
a bungalow in west hollywood and that
there was a whole i heard that's how you
got into true romance
you gave him a [ __ ] hand and that's
why we met on a saturday
and the business was shut down one of
his cigars so to speak
um [ __ ] new york
yes basketball fan knicks fans
all these [ __ ] knicks fans who've
lived in brooklyn and have been
liv die hard [ __ ] knicks fans all of
a sudden the new jersey nets
move into their borough and then all of
a sudden they're just all brooklyn net
fans and when
are they all brooklyn their fans enough
of them are that it's shocking to me
the fact that when they were beating the
knicks in the end
when brooklyn played when they played in
brooklyn and you knew that the uh the
nets were going to beat the next
that all those people were standing up
going brooklyn yeah yeah yeah bro like
taunting
the new york knicks like to me that's
like some benedict arnold [ __ ] well i i
here's the thing
here's the thing is that please explain
me what the thing is
get let me put it in boston terms let's
say
a team became the dorchester ducks
a basketball team and they were like the
dorchester like i don't know boston so
well but i know that right
dorchester's like like there is a place
in dorchester and there are ducks up
there okay
but they're on the right path let's say
i want to say
let's say a team became like a sub team
of boston and it was dorchester it was
like this
neighborhood that's like very close knit
and it's a lot of pride
and a lot of people have come through
there and it's it's a working-class
neighborhood
brooklyn is that i get that and i think
it's cool that there's a team oh
go ahead i don't know but so that that
that's the thing so i think
some people flipping are is because of
that
because it's like yo this is brooklyn
like if you're from brooklyn and you
grew up a knicks fan some brooklyn guy
for me i'm curious who are going to be
the brooklyn net fans well here's my
question
but the next the knicks are on a [ __ ]
tear yeah they beat the heat last night
they're like what like twelve and four
something like that thirteen and four
something crazy right i don't count my
chickens with that [ __ ] okay
by the way you can get in let's just say
hypothetical
they finally pushed through this year
and they win a championship
and all those people in brooklyn who've
been sick they're going to be pissed and
they went through all you know the
finger roll instead of the dunk they
went through all the [ __ ] [ __ ] with
the knicks
right and all of us and and like you're
not going to be rude years and years and
years and that's just like i i look
i guess i get it to a certain extent if
you're a kid like i get like right
little kids
if like oh brooklyn i'm from brooklyn
i'll be on that but if you're some
guy in his 30 years old so whatever you
started watching when you're 6 20. you
got
a quarter of a century of [ __ ] just
rooting for this team and then all of a
sudden another then [ __ ] new jersey
nets the new jersey nets
the new jersey nets the [ __ ] it's
it's
it's an interesting thing i don't know
it is it's going to be a conflict of
interest because the crazy thing is
they're both doing well
and if they play each other in the
playoffs it's going to it's going to be
interested like i would be curious like
when at the brooklyn arena at the
barclays arena which i haven't been to
which i'm going to go to that it annoys
me how nice that place is compared to
the celtics i just saw it on tv it's
[ __ ] ridiculous i heard it's really
nice
they got the uh the little sweets that
they have up there they're like little
mini brown stones that's that's what
that's what the floor is supposed to
look like like i guess if you have a
nice brown stone yeah yeah yeah that's
the pattern of the wood on the floor
that's crazy and then you look at the
[ __ ] celtics yeah we have the parquet
floor whatever
but it they just it's just a bunch of
cinderblocks well it's your fault
no character you knocked that [ __ ] box
down the boston garden dude
get the [ __ ] out of my house right now
you knock that [ __ ] box down
[ __ ] [ __ ] you knock that that piss hole
down right that [ __ ]
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait i
know where this is coming from you guys
i'm standing up now
where you [ __ ] this guy i'm not
please i know that this guy's about to
assault me no no well you guys could
never win i get it
kenny skywalker listen bernard king
listen patrick ewing
you guys came through and they all lost
to the show
i just want to say i just want to say
shamrock you guys knock that [ __ ] hole
down
and then you have a new arena what's it
called the fleet center the [ __ ]
fleet center you should have
you shouldn't call it you should have
done that you should have you know made
it
and stuff but you cut corners what does
that mean make it nice like the bar
clays make it nice like
you know okay do something nice to it
but you wanted to make a [ __ ] box
knock the one down and then make another
[ __ ] box that fleet center i walked by
it
it looks like you should go to the
boston garden i've never been there you
sound like a guy who's never gone to the
boston garden
i've never been in it would you consider
did you think yeah i know because it
didn't mean
you go didn't you go on that tour of
fenway we were we were we together there
oh we did get on with your insult
that [ __ ] place that no is that not
oh the history the history is great i
could go to the museum for his life
it was a piss hole if they sold mouse
ears there like you were at disneyland
you would have bought them you loved it
bill
told me you loved it aside from that
history
aside from the history is it not a [ __ ]
box you ca i couldn't even fit in some
of those seats
it's a [ __ ] there's poles blocking yeah
it's just [ __ ]
it's it's character okay so barclays
wanted to revamp there and make a nice
arena god bless them no
no no no no i'm not giving them [ __ ] i
think it's great that they did that
but what i'm saying is that you went
from oh the fans
that you went from the boston garden
yeah being a [ __ ] place that was
i mean if you consider winning 16 titles
there a [ __ ] i didn't say what they
weren't good i'm just saying the garden
itself was a piss box
listen i'm not gonna say i didn't need a
coat of paint i'm not gonna say that the
electrical didn't crap
out on you every once in a while i'm not
saying that i'm not saying that
all right but it's better than the
[ __ ] madison square garden my friend
they don't call
they let's you can't tell me what do
they call it what do they call madison
square
garden what do they call it what do they
call madison the most the most famous
arena in the world yeah and you know
it'll never get knocked down this is the
thing and we revamped it first of all
that's the second one they already
knocked down the first one i know they
knew your history
i know that but the first one was a piss
box secondly
the [ __ ] most famous arena in the
world you know who came up with that
the people who [ __ ] own the thing
well they're they're good marketing
people right that's all i'm saying
if i if i what if i i anoint myself a
[ __ ] nickname you're going to
you should call them to come up with
something some some kind of something
about the fleet center because
michael jackson just said it's like
almost not even in boston it's like
i went there i was like where is this
place no it's like a no it's in downtown
boston downtown i don't know it just
seemed weird you don't like coffee
no i like that we've won a bunch of
titles i liked it i was
us working on the heat what did you like
there the swan boats
i like the kids i like the food i
respect the sports
how could you not respect them i love
larry joe bird it's his birthday today
larry joe bird
love him is it really a real big boston
fan it's like
joseph solids we're taping this on the
seventh it's his birthday too i never
knew they had the same bird and he loved
larry bird
i asked him why did you like him over
magic johnson because he goes
because larry made me feel like i could
make the league too right
yeah he made it feel like anyone could
do it yeah so that's right
this is the this is the i'll tell you a
thing about the boston celtics and i'll
tell you something after your thing go
ahead i grew up hating the celtics i
couldn't even appreciate how good they
were and how good larry bird was
although x because we killed the knicks
everybody i hated them
right and people used to my nickname in
brooklyn is larry bird
because of the way i look and you know
dude if you could grow one of those
awful mustaches
no it's just my coloring i don't look
like larry bird no i don't look like him
we just i
just because i play basketball and i
have you know but i never had a [ __ ]
what did he have a shag or or
what is it they had the haircut every
white dude had in the eighties everybody
had that i did
it i didn't have it i didn't have a
mullet but i was feathered you feathered
it
i did feather of course you did it i
should have appeared i bet you had some
sort of uh with your liking
of hip-hop and everything you probably
had one of those thin puerto ricans
i wish shaped up but at the time at the
time when larry looked like larry bird
no at the time i was too young to have
one but i
also would have but but i'll tell you
something i told you this
i really love the celtics team that they
have now and what they did to miami last
year
pushing them to game seven and that was
one of my favorite team celtic teams of
all
me too all heart i was rooting for them
so hard
and and i've had mixed feelings about
kevin garnett especially now he's a
celtic i respect him i love his career
he's
awesome the way he plays is inspires me
is in what i do
he plays at the same level and they went
out on their [ __ ] shields last year
and
almost beat those [ __ ] because
i don't care who it is the knicks
the nets the utah jazz the [ __ ] new
orleans
pelicans or whatever they're becoming
somebody needs to beat the heat
you don't like to see me i feel that way
about the lakers
i hate the lakers and i actually think
kobe bryant this will get me some
[ __ ] emails i think he's one of the
most overrated crazy
five-time champions crazy time well go
ahead i can argue it
what what can you say he he's been on
nothing but pile on teams
like everything that they give lebron
[ __ ] for doing going to miami
kobe has been living he just hasn't had
to leave because they bring everybody in
do what he did the other night when he
walked off the court with 10 seconds
left did you see that [ __ ]
yeah yeah dude you know what it was four
seconds
four seconds whatever you did you left
your teammate sitting out there all it
does is breed resentment that guy
is a cancer he's one of the greatest
individual one-on-one players
ever since jordan i would say he's
number two behind jordan but he doesn't
make anybody better around him he he
breeds [ __ ] resentment
i agree i so i love cole's what kills me
he's a neck he's a blood he's a he's an
animal and that's what he has over the
rest
no listen i don't know here's the debate
i have to say this before people say do
you think toby would have played with
the five stitches
do you think kobe bryant would have
played with the five stitches and i'm
not disrespecting carmelo i love you
but do you think kobe bryant would have
played with the five could be missing a
leg
and he would play he would have played
against miami last night that's the
difference between him and everybody
else but this is my criticism of the guy
the guy does not know how to get along
with other [ __ ] people
he's a savant
[ __ ] ran shaq out of town like he
said the other day they go you're going
to score your 30th thousand point did
you ever think you'd do that
and he says well you know i'm not into
individual stuff i'm just was to me it
was always about champions it's like
that's why you ran
shaq out of town at the height of his
[ __ ] powers he'd won three
championships
in four years shaq leaves the very next
year he wins one with the heat
but but you got your 50 a game i'm not
saying that he
he he hasn't done some things that he
probably regrets he would never say this
but i'm saying i love that guy and his
game and i've learned to appreciate him
and and his tenacity and his intensity
listen listen
they're not saying anything that nobody
hasn't said all they do is blow
kobe and i'm not blowing him he makes
you're [ __ ] giving him
i'm a knicks fan so what i'll give him
he deserves a [ __ ] hand job
and you know what i was at that wait
first let's go back he would have played
with the stitches that carmelo
mike down you're talking too loud
carmelo i love carmelo is [ __ ] he's
sick and he's becoming a great great
team player and a winner and
and and and all that he is and i i've
definitely seen that and his talent is
is immense
his his talent is immense but last night
while i was watching that game and like
he might play he might not play
you know who would have played with last
night with five stitches on your
non-shooting and allen iverson would
have played
kobe bryant would have absolutely would
michael jordan i'm not questioning
the guy's heart anyone else in the his
inability
to get along with other [ __ ] guys has
[ __ ] the lakers like i i feel like
dude the amount of times
i'm trying to think like all those
championship runs in the finals
when is he just taking over a [ __ ]
series has he ever done that
didn't he do that against you guys when
that series that we just
did not we they just beat you like what
was it this was his quote
they just beat us last time he said i
don't know how he won that game the mvp
of the game seven of that series
was it was the [ __ ] officiating crew
we
we dude that we i'm not working they
beat you they called like [ __ ] beat
you yes they did they won and
this is my thing dude if somebody beats
me like the [ __ ] giants
they [ __ ] beat us i don't i don't i
mean in the super bowl last year
and the super bowl before that you mean
when they beat their patriots twice and
they beat them
yes they did you remember they did oh
that's right oh sorry okay
you mean when they beat them when you
guys were 18-0 yeah i just got to let
you get through this go ahead
and then they beat you in the super bowl
yeah are you talking about that year or
you told me last year
i'm talking about last year when they
beat you in the super bowl
was that last year i'm sorry i get
confused i'm not good with tiny good you
feel better i'm just i get confused feel
better but you're talking about when the
giants beat the new england patriots in
the last two super bowls i know it's
hatred
i give it up i definitely give it up
okay
but my thing about the uh a celtics this
is i'm just saying as a fan here
celtics lakers finals should be decided
by the players you put your [ __ ]
whistle away you don't call 35 [ __ ]
files on one team so
and i sat there and i watched the lakers
make
a fourth quarter comeback against the
celtics from the [ __ ]
foul line i remember if you tell me one
memorable
[ __ ] shot in that [ __ ] game
there's only one
was meta world peace he hit a
three-pointer and the only thing that
made it memorable
is was he was so [ __ ] high on
whatever the [ __ ] his therapist gave him
he was waving to the crowd like he was
already at the [ __ ] parade
that was that was the only memorable
other than that it was rasheed wallace
just standing there as kobe jumps into
him
which i can see in no call but to call a
[ __ ] offensive file like and kobe
said at the end of the game because i
don't know how we won that game
all right so i'm saying that this guy
he's sick
in individual [ __ ] individual
yeah you're one of those guys probably
thought peyton manning was better than
brady too for the longest
no no no no no no no no i'm not saying
there's not flaws
i went through my hating my coat my with
hating my hating kobe phase two
but i don't listen i respect you you
think you think they're sick you would
think that i hate the guy
i don't i don't but my [ __ ] thing
about that guy is
he's really what in a very openly way
a [ __ ] cancer he's the bobby fisher
of the nba
he's like he he he's you know what he is
he's reverse magic johnson where magic
johnson
could walk into a locker room and look
at me
on his team inexplicably and he could
somehow figure out
where he needed to give me the ball
which would probably be right under the
[ __ ] net
and he would i would somehow get eight
points i agree
kobe would walk in and would [ __ ] be
like get that [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] out
of here
and tell you to get the [ __ ] out of here
and people think that's because
he gives a [ __ ] about he gives a [ __ ]
about himself dude those championships
he doesn't go to the front [ __ ]
office
because he wants the lakers and the team
to win a championship
he like that winning championships is
another individual stack for him it's
all about [ __ ] him
that's that's i'm not gonna that's my
complaint about that guy i'm not gonna
argue or or debate with you about any of
that [ __ ]
i think the guy is [ __ ] though i'm
going to say that in the best way
and in fact one on one the only one this
year he dates
the fact that he he's never you're never
going to see him dip
he's never going to dip no absolutely
absolutely but the thing about it is
though is
if you really give a [ __ ] about winning
championships you don't walk off out on
your team dude he made everybody on that
team his
[ __ ] at that point i know it becomes
his dude
and [ __ ] dwight when did he become
dwight howard by the way
what are you saying that everyone dwight
howard said l.a though the stew and
those guys on the list
last night on on tbs when i was watching
your knicks beat the heat everyone was
going dwight howard
i don't know i don't like his headband i
think it's [ __ ] with him
take that headband off how old are you
grow up
what are you doing put it on straight do
something i don't like the headband dude
they've brought every
another thing too about his five they've
brought everybody in short of jesus
christ to help this guy get five [ __ ]
rings and then they compare him to kobe
bryant who had luke longley and bill
carter
jordan yeah i'm sorry to jordan that's
who he won with give me a [ __ ] break
all right listen the the rings of the
rings
and and that's the ring is the thing
that's not it that's not it it's
different it's like the steroid era and
not the steroid ever this is the pylon
era they should there should be oh it is
the pilot
give me a [ __ ] in miami started it
huh miami started that [ __ ]
the lakers been piloting you guys in
boston
that was a pylon champion yeah yeah so i
can [ __ ] admit that
yeah it's a pylon championship miami's
was a pilot in l.a dude
shaq phil jackson and all those [ __ ]
guys that was a pilot like
they did they like the yankees of
[ __ ] basketball i agree they just
every year
they're going to be signing these i
agree i'm not a latest fan
like that i'm not going to sit here and
defend the lakers and the way like that
i'm just saying
i want somebody to make sure they beat
the heat i love the showtime lakers
and as much as i hated those guys like
back then when like they had a crew too
but this is the but yeah but it was like
draft picks but the whole nba was
different then
i know but i wish it went back to that
where it was just like
year after [ __ ] year you got to groom
your guys when the sixers came
in you knew who was coming to town and
you had [ __ ] three years of [ __ ]
hate
i agree now it's like the guy you
[ __ ] hate the most the next year all
of a sudden he's on your team
i agree with the [ __ ] hat on and it's
it's
what ray allen did i i'm with kevin
garnett i don't say hello i'm on that
[ __ ]
i as a boston fan don't mind what he did
because he wasn't ours to begin with we
we got him as a free agent fine but we
knew what he was go there
they'll go down there to miami because
that's the way it's done now they all
[ __ ] hang out and drink pina coladas
and yeah off season
they're all friends what if you you and
you and me all got on the show
[ __ ] and then and then we're like
larry in in magic see you're coming
around to my side no i'm with that
i don't like all that it's all that aau
[ __ ] they all grew up together
that's the problem with the nba they all
grew up together playing basketball
since they were 11 12 years old
you're not going to fight them moses
malone
met bill lambie on a basketball court
moses malone met doctor
went against kareem abdul-jabbar when
they came out there magic and larry the
first time they went out
they they went face-to-face with playing
against each other right
this [ __ ] they do now they're they they
travel and they're 11 12.
everybody's kissing and hugging they're
all friends that's what's wrong with the
nba you think they're [ __ ] lonnie
shelton
was hanging out with daryl dawkins hell
[ __ ] no
you know who lonnie shelton is lonnie
shelton is a seattle
seattle superstar he was like a goon you
think that bob lanier and artist gilmore
were like you know yucking it up during
the off season in in kabul
[ __ ] no yeah these guys are all kissing
and hugging that's what i
so my thing is even in the nfl scene
cause i already always sound like a
[ __ ] crabby old man with a tampon
but like my thing is is if that's how
it's done now
that's how it's done now but don't
[ __ ] put these people
in the same uh category as larry bird
who you know coming we played like a
bunch of sissies last night no [ __ ]
layups this game and like that type of
[ __ ] no it won't happen
it's gone it's gone you'll never see the
two like when doc and larry fought that
was shocking
you will never see that happen now you
like lebron and kobe won't get into a
fist fight
what dwyane wade did to kobe last year
during the all-star game
see that's why i like kobe bryant see
but like remember
i like him too i i like him but i'm just
saying like he's on that [ __ ] but this
is the thing dude he's on that line
i think about kobe's if he acts like a
[ __ ] [ __ ] like stephen a smith was
still blowing the guy it's just like
dude he walked off this
from his [ __ ] team call him out i
agree i agree but
kobe's on that [ __ ] though that old
school [ __ ] like he's like
[ __ ] these guys he's literally like
[ __ ] these guys
and i like that [ __ ] these guys [ __ ]
these guys i think he's like [ __ ] these
guys when he's playing you and at the
end of the year
he goes uh [ __ ] this those guys just
beat us get get us their best guy
i don't know about all that but i like
that he's like [ __ ] these guys and i
like that garnett
is like [ __ ] these guys and you want to
go to the miami heat
then [ __ ] you jesus shuttlesworth [ __ ]
you
i like that he's like i see what you're
saying no kobe is is a hard guy to hate
even as a [ __ ] celtic fan but
my it just pisses me off when they
compare these guys today
where he's the closest comparison you
can make though no he isn't
yes he is and all the guys left kobe
bryant is the closest comparison
not even close i didn't see i said i
said he's the closest and you're saying
that even close
well i'm he doesn't make anybody around
him better he's all about himself he's
not about the team
i agree like magic wasn't like that
larry wasn't like that doctor jay would
you know what i'm saying
of that tenacity chamberlain was like
that yeah well
that's a whole other story i'm just
saying i'm just saying
i'm just trying bill russell is the most
overrated icon
isn't it sports it was like it was like
when lebron was playing in high school
you know those clips of him playing high
school the people
the pimple-faced you know 17 year old
that's what bill russell was when he was
playing in the nba i'm not saying he
wasn't great but he never got to compete
against
you know consistently good competition
if you're only
playing chamberlain he's not a good just
just just jerry west
these are not centers these are not
centers of course you're gonna block
every shot you're seven feet everywhere
the biggest guy is i know we beat white
guys a lot we beat you guys a lot
we're in convert where this is coming
from just saying that whole the eleven
championships
whatever look no i'll go i'll go with
this i'll go with this um
what would bill what would bill russell
be now he'd be like he'd be like uh
you know what he'd be in the nba today
he'd be like serge ibaka if he was lucky
no that's if he was lucky no that's if
you teleported him
but if he actually came up in this era
with his with his talent
with bass the basketball knowledge i'm
gonna get so much trouble for saying
that
the nutrition that they have they'd all
be bulked up you can't compare different
errors but i will say this
early on you know like those every sport
has that [ __ ] team that that went on
a run
back during the 23 skadoo years yeah you
know what i mean yeah and it's just like
you could do
yeah you can you can you just like all
right well i mean i probably could have
made the [ __ ] league back then
me too because it just came in i mean
which i couldn't but the only
like the person like like the yankees
are a team as much as i [ __ ] hate
them where
the what makes them the greatest
franchise ever i think more so than you
know the 27 that they talked about
is that they went babe ruth
to lou gehrig to joe dimaggio to mickey
mantle you're talking like
40 [ __ ] years yeah of getting jordan
yes in a row just like and everybody
else is scouting people
i mean we [ __ ] sold babe ruth we were
morons that's why i hated the curse of
babe
i i thought that was a cop-out it's like
no we're [ __ ] idiots
right there wasn't no curse it was just
you guys [ __ ] up
unbelievably yeah and deserved every not
the fans
but the organization does they could
have gotten different channels you guys
those titles
they could have given uh don't give us
what titles the two titles you won i
don't even they don't
really count him you know how good this
makes me feel i think it probably makes
like any laker fan to list me bitching
about kobe how happy that made them
those titles don't even count to me yeah
why would they they just don't count
yeah why would they count to you
because they're just whatever man go
ahead guys we were just down three games
to none to a 215 million dollar team
you know we came back oh you do you know
that'll never happen again
no unless the new york yankees do it to
have another
215 million dollar team with like four
first ballot hall of famers choke away
four games in a row you're never going
to see it again unless the [ __ ]
yankees do it because they're the only
ones who can afford
that 250 million dollar [ __ ] team yes
yeah that's all i'm gonna say yes yeah
you just gotta you gotta take that one
the same way i gotta take your giant
[ __ ]
oh you mean when they beat their [ __ ]
patriots
it all yeah back it's a circle speaking
the curse of the babe
somebody wanted me to ask you this go
ahead let me see here
evidently you were on one of those ghost
stories yes
celebrity ghost stories thing and they
bluntly asked ah where the [ __ ] is it
it was totally real that's what they
said see you knew they were gonna say
they wouldn't say how full of [ __ ]
hang on i gotta see this here no but we
got part two the part two is is even
better it's coming up on um
[ __ ] i don't know the name of the new
show but it's uh
something something and we went back to
school me and the friend that it's
pretty good well tell me what happened
because i missed it i i know i'm
familiar with the show where it's like
celebrities i had an encounter with a
ghost man and then i and i went and i
told it and it was real and i'm such a
bull you believe in ghosts
listen i for i i had a ghost encounter
i can't find the [ __ ] thing all right
a second wait a second so
take me through this because i think i
think you're just afraid of the dark
no no no i'm not it was it was in high
school i went to a really old high
school
billy cunningham went to doug moe and
barbra streisand
oh okay and the rapper special ed wow
yeah that's a pretty eclectic it was a
collectible mix of people
rasmussel high school in brooklyn okay
and wait i thought you're from manhattan
right now but that's when i went to high
school i had gotten kicked out of every
dude we're at an hour and seven times
efforted listen to this oh [ __ ]
yeah yeah let's knows i gotta hear you
go let's wrap it up with the ghost story
no it's not worth it trust me yes it is
i promise because i want to give you
[ __ ] about this no i promise you it's
not
there's other things give me no no [ __ ]
you you saw a ghost i want to hear this
all right when we were in high school we
got locked in a room and [ __ ] was
we were 15 years old and we got the [ __ ]
scared out of us and you know my friend
but we went on the thing and i talked
about it but the the partners no no no
no
slow it down where did you're in you you
were in this high school
it's really old it's a really old high
school there's ghosts in there like it's
known
and it's known that there's ghosts so
you're in there and you're going to your
science class
is this after hours it was after school
it was like during um
dusk ghosts never come out there was
nothing we had uh we had detention
you had detention it was like it was
like the urban urban uh version of the
breakfast club okay
it was like the brooklyn version of the
breakfast club so
you know it was like that and we got so
instead of weed he had coke
yeah coke crack okay you know we're
sniffing it no
and we're drinking beers in 40s but even
it
you know you know they make things seem
heightened on the on the celebrity ghost
stories
so it's okay
oh my god okay
all right okay all right well we just
deep it's just it's too hard to talk
about bill
it's emotional it makes me yeah i don't
want to get so because i'm we're taught
yet
yeah and it brings you to a bad spot
yeah i i want you to have a good time so
i don't want to bring up your your true
life ghost story that you're told yeah
the reason i wanted to tell you the
reason why i'm wearing my tell me it's
changed the subject the reason why i'm
wearing my giants t-shirt and my
matching giant sneakers
is because my son has his playoff game
today he looks like a make-a-wish kid
with that matching [ __ ] on but go ahead
because we're we have our playoff game
today okay i have to get to the field an
hour and a half before to check the
grass to make sure everything's good
because
you know it's it's the uh it's uh what's
he playing uh soccer football
football football but it's it but you
know he's ten
i you know i i i'm the inspire i'm not
the coach but i'm the the inspirational
leader of the team
and i have to get there at that fireman
exactly
what i am okay that's exactly what i am
i'm uh of the of the barrington
of the barrington uh uh 10 year old uh
uh
league i am the fireman of great death
we won the super bowl last year and we
have our playoff game today
and you know there's other yelling at
the other little kids that's right [ __ ]
i know i never i i'm actually very good
in that way but i will say
one game that we played it wasn't tony
gonzalez's kid but
tony gonzalez's kid was on that team
this year
we were losing and i was i was like
we're going to win this game with three
touchdowns
and and every time we'd score a
touchdown not tony is a gonzalez's kid
right but he was on their team
but this fat kid again not not tony's
kid
was like what's the big deal you you
just got one touchdown
and i ignored them the first time this
is a kid in the crowd no on their team
because i'm going nuts so this is a fat
kid on the other team a fat kid on the
other hand nine year old at this point
between 10 and 12. he could be 10 or 12.
the way he's making himself 12. so you
don't sound that bad
12. he's hot he's hocking me what's the
big deal
hey i don't say anything to him and then
we score again now we're down six points
these guys he said this to me this is a
little kid that this guy's getting so
excited every time they score
i'm looking over and i'm like and then i
said hey don't don't speak to me you're
not allowed to talk to me
and then when we won the game we finally
went ahead i did yeah because
i'm like i want to be like you fat [ __ ]
listen get off the twinkies
okay and then you know stock up and you
could say that back in the day too
right you could you could literally duke
it out with his dad
and in the end even though his blood and
teeth in the ground there would be no
losses nothing
nothing anyway we won the game and after
the game you know you line up in the
handshake
and tubby you saw me because he was like
this guy's
nuts but i'm always really you know i'm
i i you know what you're in the stance
so why are you out on the field no i'm
an inspirational leader
i'm the only racial so i was actually
because we were losing they brought me
at halftime to come over there and give
a speech
oh there you go so i gave a speech it's
like my
version of hoosiers every week i love it
but anyway so i gave
sl i gave fatso a nice a good a good
five and a pop on the
on the ass after the game and said good
game and smith
they get mad enough no but he knew that
we had a little thing
and it was like you know it was like
that moment in um in the hangover you
know when the little kid was like
but i was the little kid i was like [ __ ]
you
so hopefully we'll play them in the in
the playoffs they're the the chiefs
they're the ones where where are they at
right now what level is it
is it the first round of the playoffs is
this today's the first round of the
playoffs
oh okay and we're playing a kid we're
playing i have a speech plan out today
and it's about us being a team
and being brothers and them having just
one good player and are you gonna let
one good player beat you brothers
something like that there you go i don't
want to blow my load right now but it's
a really good speech i have it written
down
dude you know what we're at the end here
and you know what i completely forgot to
bring up that
i loved was the documentary oh thank you
on uh on uh tribe called
thank you thank you and there was a
question that if people didn't see it
like
i'm one of those people came way way
late today right we talked about
so like there's a bunch of stuff that
you know like i was obviously familiar
with them and i knew
a lot of their stuff yeah yo mtv rappers
put down but i didn't know
to the level all of this stuff it was
such a like even if you're not a fan of
that music
you'll love it you love this documentary
and then you'll actually like me you'll
start downloading all uh
their music is for everybody i call them
the rolling stones of hip-hop their
music is
you can't not like the music or the
beatles of hip-hop like their music is
just
that accessible in all ages tribe called
quest it was a pleasure doing it
the name of the film is b trams in life
the travels of a tribe called quest it
was a
and everything's good everything's
smoothed over i know there was a little
bit of drama there everything is smooth
i mean i think
you know that was all because they are
very protective
and and and and you know they understand
what the
legacy of a tribe called quest means to
the fans i do too that's why i
made the movie i came at it as a fan i
love the group
and i didn't know anything about them
and i didn't think it showed them in a
bad way it just made me want to download
their stuff and
respected them that's why i made the
movie that's why i made it you know yeah
it's fine
i mean it wasn't the first time a
documentary director got into it with
the subjects of a documentary it's not
gonna be the last time
um i think it does i think people freak
out right before it comes out you're
like oh my god is this gonna is this
gonna ruin me
it'd be like i understand do you know uh
burt reynolds i heard before uh
boogie nights right like freaked out he
walked out of a screening yeah maybe
even fired his agent he was just like
what
why did you put me in this piece of [ __ ]
now it's like like everybody loves it
trust me if somebody was filming a
documentary of
of of my life and they were doing this
segment you think i'd want this segment
and our celebrity ghost story thing to
be i'd be like no that can't make it
into the [ __ ] movie
so i understand i i understood because i
would i thought about a lot i'd be like
how would you feel if somebody's making
a doc that was beyond
just me being the incredible incredible
you know
highly achieved actor you know it became
this personal thing if they just didn't
want to go into
me as a highly highly highly achieved
actor no i'm just playing but
you know when it gets personal and you
like you start to see like the intimacy
and
you see yourself in moments that you
forgot about because they're being
filmed
they're on screen it's a vulnerable
position so that's all it was
and i made the movie out of love and and
i think at the end of the day
they know that and and the movies gone
on to
you know it's really like what else you
got anything uh you want to hype before
we uh
nah man i mean the only thing i want to
hype is is the new york knicks i want to
hype the giants
you know starting to do their little
mid-season fumble and you know we got a
movie coming out in
in i think it's april 5th this year
sandra bullock
bill burr is incredible and he's funny
he's good he's got red hair
and a red beard now yo there's there's
going to be
bill burr is going to be doing his thing
in this movie it's going to be it's a
funny movie and uh
all right i'm really psyched that you
came on this i'm glad to do it
definitely we're gonna we might have to
have you on again to talk [ __ ] when the
patriots finally beat your ass in the
[ __ ] super bowl
we should do listen we gotta go we'll do
a heat we'll do a thing for the heat
that'll be after football season it'll
be going into the playoffs of of
for basketball and and baseball just be
starting we'll do it i'm always a
pessimist
i hate our defense i hate our secondary
for the patriots i think the best thing
we have going for our secondary is our
[ __ ] running game because it keeps
them off the goddamn field so you know
your [ __ ]
i'm gonna tell you this right now like i
think i think i think we're going to
lose to the broncos in the playoffs
i really do because would that be the
first round
that would they're they're not wild card
right no no no we we're uh
no broncos are going to win that
division right and we're going to win
our so maybe like second round i just
feel like
i think you know because belichick knows
how to get into peyton's head but like
i i just i just don't believe in our
defense and also that when we played the
broncos earlier this year peyton had
only been with them for 60 days yeah
that doesn't count now he's going to be
yeah now he's gelling with them and he's
gonna have another hundred and twenty
days he'll be like twenty
something two to three hundred [ __ ]
days in 240 days in or something he's
something else yeah yeah i know
no absolutely yeah and i'm so glad that
he came back because who would have
wanted him to end
i didn't want you know what i ended up
realizing that i never really hated
peyton manning what i really [ __ ]
hated was
the disrespect that they they weren't
giving brady his [ __ ] do it's a long
[ __ ] argument
and at the end of it you know there's no
way he's a football fan you can't love
that guy but i i
think that that defense is good enough
with brady and belichick he could never
counter that's going to be good
that's going to be a brutal game but
what about gronkowski is he going to
come back
i love gronkowski by the way yeah i
don't know he's it's what he breaks for
he'll i guarantee you he'll be he'll be
there
he's i love him i love gronkowski
he's he's he's good he reminds me of my
radio welcome
if he caught that [ __ ] ball you're
not working what do you mean you talking
about that little loop that barely
come on man listen you lost the game
and blood spilled twice first time it
happened you came back you got surgery
rehabilitation and then we
slit them again you left us on light so
far you can't we gotta play it up again
we gotta play you guys again all right
michael thank you so much for coming on
man you're [ __ ] awesome
i appreciate it and that ghost story was
[ __ ] that was really good that was
incredible
you